I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Happy birthday everybody. It is Michael's birthday.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们正在做终极版《办公室》重温播客，专属于你们。每周我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。大家生日快乐。今天是迈克尔的生日。
Michael, it should be day. Oh my gosh. Oh, Angela, he would be so happy if anyone responded to his birthday like that. Yeah, this guy needs a party like nobody else. He needs the party. It's so true guys, it's season two episode 19. Michael's birthday written by Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stupnitzky directed by Ken Wittingham. Guys,
迈克尔，这应该就是今天。哦天哪。哦，安吉拉，如果有人那样对他的生日做出反应，他会高兴坏的。是的，这家伙比任何人都需要一个派对。他需要这个派对。千真万确，伙们，这是第二季第19集。由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯普尼茨基编剧，肯·威丁厄姆执导的《迈克尔的生日》。伙计们，
I'm in my closet right now. I am in my that's what she said this morning. My husband figured out how to try to sound proof at Sam. I don't know if we did it. We tried, but we got a shower curtain out of the guest room. And Josh put it across the shed and hung some blankets on it. We took, you know, the clamps that our kids have a fort building kit. Wow. And we took all of their clamps. So I hope the kids don't get to do a fort this week because mom is trying to podcast from home. The best part of seeing you right now on this video chat while we do this is that you are wearing a set of gamer headphones.
我现在在我的壁橱里。我今天早上说的就是这个。我丈夫想出了怎么给萨姆隔音。我不知道我们是不是成功了。我们试过了，但我们从客房里拿出一个浴帘。乔什把它挂在棚子上，并在上面挂了一些毯子。我们拿了，你知道的，我们孩子城堡搭建套装里的那些夹子。哇。我们拿了他们所有的夹子。所以我希望孩子们这周不要搭城堡了，因为妈妈正试图在家录播客。现在在这个视频聊天中看到你的最好部分是，你戴着一套游戏耳机。
Yes, I am. I have a giant microphone, but I've pointed it up to the sky. Like an antenna coming out of your ear. Yeah, that's true. And we're gonna put a photo of this on the pod. Should I do a summary? Here it is. Do a summary, babe.
是的，我是。我有一个巨大的麦克风，但我把它指向天空了。就像一根从你耳朵里伸出来的天线。是的，没错。我们打算把这张照片发到播客上。我需要做个总结吗？就是这样。做个总结，宝贝。
I don't know why I called you, babe. I don't know. I don't know either. Do a summary, babe. It's Michael's birthday, and he is desperate to be the center of attention. Meanwhile, we learn that Kevin is waiting for the results of a mole biopsy.
我不知道我为什么叫你宝贝。我不知道。我也不知道。做个总结，宝贝。今天是迈克尔的生日，他极度渴望成为人们关注的焦点。与此同时，我们得知凯文正在等待痣活检的结果。
Yes. Kevin is very worried. He might have skin cancer. And this is causing a distraction to Michael's birthday that he is unhappy with. Oh my gosh. Michael's like, today is the day for celebration. And you guys are all worried about Kevin. And I am grumpy about it.
是的。凯文非常担心。他可能得了皮肤癌。这分散了大家对迈克尔生日的注意力，他对此很不高兴。哦天哪。迈克尔觉得，今天是庆祝的日子。而你们都在担心凯文。对此我很生气。
Yeah. That was my summary. I like it, babe. Babe, I like it. Yeah. That was my summary. I like it, babe. Babe, I like it. Babe. Okay, wait, are we just gonna jump right in? Should we jump right in? There's more summary.
是的。那是我的总结。我很喜欢，宝贝。宝贝，我很喜欢。是的。那是我的总结。我很喜欢，宝贝。宝贝，我很喜欢。宝贝。好吧，等等，我们要直接进入正题吗？我们应该直接切入正题吗？还有更多总结。
And fast facts. You've forgotten everything. Wow. There's more summary. What is happening? Also, in this episode, Dwight and Angela really bicker over who exactly isn't charged of planning Michael's birthday party.
还有快速事实。你什么都忘了。哇。还有更多总结。发生什么事了？此外，在本集中，德怀特和安吉拉真的为了究竟谁负责策划迈克尔的生日派对而争吵不休。
Is it Dwight as his right hand man or is it Angela head of the PPC? This is the first time we're going to see a little tension going on between Dwight and Angela. Yeah. Well, I mean, there was tension in season one over who was the security officer, you know, that was pre-them dating. So they have some issues about who gets to have control of what. They have that going into this relationship. And I have a note card, guys, that says, do Angela Sass!
是作为他得力干将的德怀特，还是派对策划委员会负责人的安吉拉？这是我们第一次看到德怀特和安吉拉之间出现一点紧张气氛。是的。好吧，我的意思是，第一季里关于谁是保安主管就曾有过紧张气氛，你知道，那是他们约会之前的事。所以他们在谁来掌控什么权力的问题上有一些争执。他们在进入这段关系时就带着这些问题。我有张便签，伙计们，上面写着：展现安吉拉的傲慢！
Ooh, do Angela Sass! All through this episode, we're gonna track it. Also in this episode, Jim and Pam, they sneak out of the office together. And in the end, the entire office gang is going to go ice skating. Who saw that coming? I didn't see that coming. Well, the writers knew that we were gonna end up at an ice skating rink.
哦，展现安吉拉的傲慢！在这一整集中，我们将追踪这个。同样在本集中，吉姆和潘，他们一起溜出了办公室。最后，整个办公室的一帮人要去滑冰。谁料到会这样？我没有料到会这样。好吧，编剧们知道我们最终会去滑冰场。
That leads me into Sam. Please play my special audio clip. Fast, fast. What is that? What is happening? We had a fan submit some little, they're called Stings, Angela. I love that so much. I didn't even know there was such a thing. Yeah, thank you. So more stings, please. More stings, guys. Send us your stings. I didn't even know that was a term.
这让我想到了萨姆。请播放我的特殊音频片段。快，快。那是什么？发生什么事了？我们有粉丝提交了一些小片段，它们被称为“刺儿音”，安吉拉。我太喜欢了。我甚至不知道还有这种东西。是的，谢谢。所以请播放更多的刺儿音。更多的刺儿音，伙计们。把你们的刺儿音发给我们。我甚至不知道那是个词。
We're learning so much. We're a hundred but thank you for making us stings. So fast fact number one is that Steve Carell is a very very good ice skater. He played hockey growing up, he played Pick-Up hockey every week as an adult. Fan question for Matt Loveless was the plot built around Steve's ability to ice skate. Yes, he's so good. He's really good. Yes, the writers had on one of their cards up on the wall. This fact about Steve being a good ice skater and they had been looking forever for a way to incorporate it. And you guys might remember that later when we filmed the threat level midnight, that again, that plot of threat level midnight, the movie, takes place in an ice skating
我们学到了好多。我们已经一百岁了，但谢谢你们为我们制作刺儿音。所以快速事实一号是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是一个非常非常好的溜冰者。他从小打冰球，成年后每周都打野球。马特·洛夫莱斯提出的粉丝问题是，剧情是围绕史蒂夫滑冰的能力构建的吗？是的，他太棒了。他真的很厉害。是的，编剧们在墙上的卡片之一写了关于史蒂夫擅长滑冰的事实，他们一直在寻找各种方法将其融入其中。你们可能还记得，后来当我们拍摄《威胁级午夜》时，那个电影的剧情再次发生在一个滑冰
rink and that was just like another opportunity to feature Steve's ice skating ability. I was at the car wash one time waiting for my car to get washed, right? like another opportunity to feature Steve's ice skating ability. I was at the car wash one time, waiting for my car to get washed, right? You know, the one you kind of, you can drive through part of it and then you wait on the other side, right? Yeah.
场，这就像是另一个展现史蒂夫滑冰能力的契机。我曾经在洗车房等我的车被洗，对吧？就像是另一个展现史蒂夫滑冰能力的契机。我曾经在洗车房等我的车被洗，对吧？你知道那种你可以开车穿过一部分然后等在另一边的洗车房，对吧？是的。
So I'm at the car wash and this guy walks up to me and goes, I ice skate with Steve, just, you know, sometimes I ice skate with Steve. And I was like, oh, what? Oh, okay. Wait a go. You're probably very good because Steve is good. Have a nice day. Well, you know, Angela, my husband Lee ice skates. He's on several pickup hockey teams and my son as well is a hockey player. And
所以我在洗车房，这个家伙朝我走过来对我说，我和史蒂夫一起滑冰，就，你知道的，有时我和史蒂夫一起滑冰。然后我说，哦，什么？哦，好吧。去吧。你可能很厉害因为史蒂夫很厉害。祝你有美好的一天。嗯，你知道，安吉拉，我丈夫李会滑冰。他参加了好几个野球队，我儿子也是一名冰球运动员，并且
my husband now plays on the pickup team that Steve used to play on. I wonder if he plays with the guy from the car wash. Steve does not play pickup hockey anymore. He told me he kind of retired from that. But back when we shot this episode, he was really into it. He was really into it. And Jenna, you're like a hockey mom. I have been on the ice with you now
我丈夫现在加入了他以前所在的史蒂夫打过的野球队。我在想他是不是和洗车房那个人一起打球。史蒂夫不再打野球了。他告诉我他基本上已经从那退休了。但当我们拍摄这一集的时候，他真的很迷恋这个。他真的很迷恋。珍娜，你就像个冰球妈妈。我现在已经和你一起上过冰了
and I've met your hockey mom friends and I am into it. I don't have a kid that plays hockey, but they told me you can drink beer at like 10 a.m. hockey matches and I'm like, oh yeah, this is the crowd I should be in. I mean, I'm over at the soccer field. They got nothing at that concession stand, maybe some pretzels. I mean, we're at these hockey rinks. Sometimes it's seven in the morning or eight in the morning and they open up that concession stand and they go for it. I am not a beer drinker but I am amazed at people's ability to have a beer in the morning. Have a beer in the morning.
我还见过了你的冰球妈妈朋友们，我很喜欢。我没有一个打冰球的孩子，但他们告诉我你可以在早上10点左右的冰球比赛中喝啤酒，然后我就想，哦，是的，这正是我应该加入的圈子。我的意思是，我在足球场那边。小卖部里什么都没有，可能只有一些蝴蝶饼。我的意思是，我们在这些冰球场。有时是早上七点或早上八点，他们就会打开小卖部开始痛饮。我不是个喝酒的人，但我对人们有能力在早上喝啤酒感到震惊。在早上喝啤酒。
Like that would do me in. But yeah, oh God, I love the hockey community. It's a great it's a great great community. I'm I love being a part of it. Alright, fast fact number two. This is a fan question from Renata. She said, this episode has several external locations. Did it take longer to produce this episode because of that? So we usually would take five days to shoot an episode and we were still able to shoot this episode in five days,
就像那会把我搞垮一样。但是，天哪，我喜欢冰球社区。这是一个非常非常棒的社区。我喜欢成为其中的一部分。好了，快速事实二号。这是来自雷娜塔的粉丝问题。她说，这一集有几个外部取景地。因为这个原因，制作这一集花的时间更长吗？所以我们通常需要五天时间来拍摄一集，我们仍然能够在五天内拍完这一集，
even with our multiple locations. And guess what I did Angela? What? I got some scoop from Kentapedia about our locations. Kent Subornak, let's hear it. All right, so first up the store that Jim and Pam go to was a right aid at Woodman and Sherman Way. Do you remember that right aid Angela? I do. I do. I do pass by it every day on the way to work and I would chop there constantly. Yeah. I would always like pick up some milk on the way home. One time I bought some socks. I was low on socks. Oh yeah. I remember setting up my trailer, you know, we would sort of decorate.
尽管我们有多个取景地。你猜我做了什么，安吉拉？什么？我从肯百科那里得到了一些关于我们取景地的独家消息。肯·苏博纳克，让我们听听。好的，首先是吉姆和潘去的商店是伍德曼街和谢尔曼路交汇处的一家赖德。你还记得那家赖德吗，安吉拉？我记得。我记得。我每天上班的路上都会经过它，我经常在那里购物。是的。我总是在回家的路上顺便买点牛奶。有一次我买了一些袜子。我的袜子不多了。哦，是的。我记得搭建我的拖车，你知道的，我们会稍微装饰一下。
And I got a few different little things. I got like a dormat. Yeah. At that right aid. Okay, so cute. You're at the right aid by us. He said that we shot there for a half a day, but we started very, very early. I think my hair and makeup started around 4am or 4.30am. I believe it. Because yeah, we had to start shooting on camera by six, and the right aid said we could only shoot there until 11 a.m. with the store closed. After 11 a.m., we could keep shooting, but they were gonna let customers in. And Kent said that we finished by 10 a.m. We finished an hour early
我弄了一些不同的东西。我弄了一个门垫。是的。在那家赖德。好吧，太可爱了。你在我们附近的赖德。他说我们在那里拍摄了半天，但我们开始得非常非常早。我想我的发型和化妆大约在凌晨4点或4点30分开始。我相信。因为是的，我们必须在六点前在镜头前开始拍摄，而且赖德说我们只能在商店关门的情况下在那里拍摄到上午11点。11点之后，我们可以继续拍摄，但他们要让顾客进来了。肯说我们在上午10点就完成了。我们提前一个小时完成了
and that all the customers that you see in those scenes are hired background performers, none of them are real customers. All right. Good job team. Good job. You got in, you got out. That's the scoop on the right aid. So the ice skating, we shot that at Pickwick IceRink in Burbank. I know this rank well. And we had the whole place to ourselves for one full day. We were there from 7 a.m. to 7 p.m. Again, we started our hair and makeup very early around 5 a.m. and we were all shooting by 7.
而且你在那些场景中看到的所有顾客都是雇来的背景演员，没有一个是真正的顾客。好的。干得好，团队。干得漂亮。你们进去了，又出来了。这就是关于赖德的独家消息。所以滑冰，我们在伯班克的皮克威克冰场拍摄的。我很熟悉这个冰场。我们整整一天都包下了整个地方。我们在那里从早上7点到晚上7点。同样，我们的发型和化妆开始得很早，大约在早上5点，我们在7点就开始拍摄了。
The other skaters in the background were background actors. We shut that place down. It was all ours. So Kent also told me that luckily both Randall Einhorn and Matt Sone, they were our camera operators that they could ice skate. And so they were skating around with cameras. Do you remember that, Angela? Because I did not remember that those guys were skating with us. I remember Randall on the ice. I do because I have a little funny backstory about there was a stunt ice skater Jenna. Do you remember the stunt ice skater? Oh, yeah, the guy who filled in for Oscar.
背景中的其他滑冰者都是背景演员。我们清场了。那完全是我们的了。所以肯还告诉我，幸运的是兰德尔·艾因霍恩和马特·索恩，他们是我们的摄像师，他们都会滑冰。所以他们扛着摄像机到处滑冰。你还记得吗，安吉拉？因为我不记得那些家伙和我们一起滑冰了。我记得兰德尔在冰上。我记得，因为我有一个有趣的幕后故事，关于有一个特技滑冰演员，珍娜。你还记得那个特技滑冰演员吗？哦，对，那个代替奥斯卡的家伙。
Yes, so you'll see later in the episode as we watch it that Oscar is like a very good ice skater He does like a kind of a pure like pure wit and spins around Well, that's because there was a stunt guy that looked like him that was a really great figure skater. And I have a little story about that. I don't know if you remember this, Jenna. But Randall was filming the stunt guy getting all of the moves, right? Yeah. And they wanted us skating in the background. And I sort of skated in the background. And I did a big circle, like I kind of opened my legs and did a big circle.
对，所以你会在稍后的剧集中看到，当我们观看它时，奥斯卡就像是一个非常好的滑冰者，他做了一种类似于纯粹的旋转之类的动作。嗯，那是因为有一个长得像他的特技演员，他是一个非常伟大的花样滑冰运动员。我有一个关于那个的小故事。我不知道你是否还记得这个，珍娜。但兰德尔正在拍摄特技演员完成所有动作，对吧？是的。他们想让我们在背景中滑冰。我有点在背景中滑开。我做了一个大圆圈，就像我有点打开双腿做了一个大圆圈。
And the guy said to me in between text, he goes, hey, he said, can you skate? And I was like, well, I can roller skate. So I'm just trying to do what I do on roller skates. And he said, come here. And he spun me around. And then Randall was like, oh, wait, I'll get this. Just in case, maybe it'll be funny that Oscar spins
那个家伙在排练间隙对我说，嘿，他说，你会滑冰吗？然后我说，嗯，我会旱冰。所以我只是在试图做我在旱冰上做的事情。他说，过来。然后他把我转了一圈。然后兰德尔就说，哦，等等，我来拍这个。以防万一，也许奥斯卡转圈会很有趣
Angela or something, you know? Okay. And so the stunt ice skater started doing all these things with me, Jenna. He spun me. He picked me up and twirled me. He had me stick one leg out and one leg up. Like, and then spun me and set me down.
安吉拉或者什么的，你知道吗？好的。所以特技滑冰演员开始和我一起做所有这些事情，珍娜。他转动我。他把我抱起来转圈。他让我伸出一条腿，抬起一条腿。就像，然后转动我把我放下来。
And we, like somewhere, there is footage of the stunt ice skater lifting me in the air and spinning me around. And it, we never, we never, is this footage. We never use the footage, but it really made me laugh to think that maybe there is a world where Angela and Oscar figure skate together. Okay, two things.
我们，在某个地方，有特技滑冰演员把我举在空中转圈的录像。而且它，我们从未，我们从未，有这个录像。我们从未使用过这段录像，但想到也许有一个安吉拉和奥斯卡一起花样滑冰的世界，真的让我笑了。好吧，两件事。
Number one, NBC release this footage immediately. Number two, Angela, do you know who that guy was? I love to talk. Tell me, tell me. Okay know who that guy was? I looked him up. Tell me, Tim. Okay, his name is Bert Jude Lankan. Okay. And he was a pair skater, a famous pair skater who won the silver medal at the 1982 United States
第一，NBC请立刻发布这段视频。第二，安吉拉，你知道那个家伙是谁吗？我太想知道了。快告诉我，快告诉我。好吧，你知道那个家伙是谁吗？我查过了。快告诉我，蒂姆。好吧，他的名字叫伯特·朱德·兰肯。好吧。他曾是一名双人滑选手，一位著名的双人滑选手，在1982年美国
Figure Skating Championships, and then later placed sixth at the 1984 Winter Olympic Games. Wow! You were figure skating with an Olympic pairs figure skater. Where is this footage? That is amazing, that is so cool. Well, you know, I'm not very good, but he was very good, so.
花样滑冰锦标赛上获得银牌，后来在1984年冬季奥运会上获得第六名。哇！你竟然跟一位奥运会双人滑选手一起滑过冰。这段视频在哪？太惊人了，太酷了。嗯，你知道，我滑得不是很好，但他非常棒，所以。
Well, I'm gonna find the footage for you. I'm gonna surprise you with it at some milestone birthday in the future. You'll have to ask Randall Einhorn, say Randall. Did any of that like end up somewhere? Oh my gosh. Okay. Well, next up is FastFac number three, but I don't even know how to follow that because that was good stuff. Picture me an Oscar right now in your mind, guys. Close your eyes. Picture me an Oscar right now
好吧，我会为你找到这段视频的。我会在未来的某个重要生日给你一个惊喜。你得去问问兰德尔·艾因霍恩，跟他说，兰德尔，那些素材最后有没有存留下来一部分？天哪。好吧，接下来是第三个冷知识，但我甚至不知道该怎么接话了，因为刚才那个太棒了。大家在脑海里想象一下我拿奥斯卡奖的样子。闭上眼睛。现在想象一下我
as a figure skating couple on the ice. And go. Oscar makes all of our costumes. Well, Angela, that is a good segue for me into FastFact number three because you mentioned costumes. We got a fan question from Alyssa, and this is not specific to this episode,
作为冰上花样滑冰双人组合在冰面上。开始。奥斯卡制作了我们所有的服装。好吧，安吉拉，这对我过渡到第三个冷知识是个很好的契机，因为你提到了服装。我们收到了粉丝阿丽莎的一个问题，这并不是针对本集的，
but a general fan question, and I thought it was a good one, so I thought we would include it. Alyssa wants to know, what do you do with your clothes after you've been shooting in the same outfit for 12 to 15 hours at a time, she says, I imagine they would get stretched out and wrinkly and dirty. Do you have multiple sets of the same outfits for each day of shooting or just someone wash them for you? First of all,
而是一个通用的粉丝问题，我觉得挺不错的，所以想把它加进来。阿丽莎想知道，当你们连续12到15小时穿着同一套衣服拍摄后，这些衣服会怎么处理？她说，我猜它们一定会变松、起皱而且很脏。你们每天拍摄时都有好几套相同的服装，还是有人专门帮你们洗？首先，
I like where her head's at. Yeah, I like this person. I know. This person is a planner. She probably packs very well for a trip. I like it. I like your train of thought These are things I wonder about when I watch movies especially if I see a movie where like it's a flood or They're submerged in water somehow. I think oh my gosh. How many hours that day did they have to stand? Like waste deep in water, probably like 12 hours. So here's the thing, we often had, well we always had duplicates, they wanted to make sure that you had two of every outfit. So they could wash and have the next set ready the next day.
我喜欢她的思路。对啊，我喜欢这个人。我知道。这个人很有规划。她去旅行时肯定行李收拾得很井井有条。我喜欢。我喜欢你的思路。这些是我看电影时也会好奇的事情，特别是当看到电影里有洪水或者他们不知怎么泡在水里的时候。我想，天哪。他们那天得在水里站多少小时？像没腰深的水里，大概12个小时吧。所以情况是这样的，我们经常，呃，我们总是有备份，他们想确保你每套衣服都有两件。这样他们就可以清洗，并准备好下一套在第二天穿。
Also if you were to spill something on it or get a tear or whatever, they would have the duplicate ready to go. Yes, and if you did have to do some sort of a stunt or something in that particular outfit, then they might have even more than two. You know, they might have seven shirts if part of the scene involves you purposely dripping ketchup on your shirt or something. So yeah, they always had multiples. And part of the wardrobe department's job is to launder and prepare your outfit for the next day. So that's how that works.
此外，如果你不小心把东西洒在上面或者撕破了什么的，他们也有备用的衣服可以随时换上。对的，如果你必须在那套特定的服装里完成某种特技或类似动作，那么他们甚至可能会准备两件以上。你知道，如果场景的一部分涉及你故意把番茄酱滴在衬衫上之类的，他们可能会准备七件衬衫。所以，是的，他们总是准备多套。服装部门的工作之一就是清洗并为你准备好第二天的服装。事情就是这样的。
I like the question though, I like the question. All right. That's the end of my fast facts. BELL RINGS Oh, I'm so sorry guys. What the f*** was that? Well, I think my bread is done. I have some bread in the oven.
不过我喜欢这个问题，我喜欢这个问题。好啦。我的冷知识讲完了。铃声响起 噢，真对不起大家。刚才那是什么鬼？嗯，我觉得我的面包烤好了。我在烤箱里烤了些面包。
I thought that was like an alert. They always say you can tell a little something about the person by which alarm they pick. And by day I mean me. This is my theory. So like your alarm is like, gang, gang, gang, like, me day, me day. And like my alarm is like, two banjos playing.
我还以为那是个警报器呢。他们总说，你可以通过一个人选择的闹钟看出他的一些特质。我说的“人”就是指我自己。这是我的理论。所以比如你的闹钟是，当，当，当，就像是，救命，救命。而我的闹钟就像是，两把班卓琴在弹奏。
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，
ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding that true. Everybody, what is your alarm on your phone? And what does it say about you? Lee is telling me that the internal temperature of my bread is only 154 degrees. Do you mind if we take a break? I do want to take a break because my that's what she should is really cold and I turn my heater off when we podcast and I want to warm it back up. So you take care of your bread, you heat up your bread, I'm going to heat up my sheet shit.
叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮 对不对。大家，你们手机的闹钟是什么样的？它说明了你什么？莉告诉我，我面包的内部温度只有154华氏度。你们介意我们休息一下吗？我真的很想休息一下，因为我那这真是太冷了，我们录播客时我把暖气关了，我想让它重新暖和起来。所以你去处理你的面包吧，你去加热你的面包，我要去热我的……靠。罪过。
And we'll be right back. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Well, I just oversaw the bread. We're still not at the right internal temperature. I had to leave it for Lee to make a judgment call I hope it turns out. I hope we can make some sandwiches today. Time will tell. Let's get back on track Jenna and let's jump into this episode. Yes, the cold open Michael is trying to sell the employees some calling cards.
我们马上回来。♪ 片尾音乐播放 ♪ 嗯，我刚才没看好面包。内部温度还是不够。我得留给莉去作决定了，希望它烤得出来。希望我们今天能做几个三明治。拭目以待吧。我们回到正题上来，珍娜，让我们切入这一集。好的，冷场开场是迈克尔试图向员工推销一些电话卡。
Did you notice something about the scene Jenna? It's in the conference room, right? Yep. Yeah. Who all is in attendance? Who? It is Jim. Dwight. Jim Dwight, Toby Creed, Oscar, Ryan, and Stanley. Not a single woman. Hey. Hey. Now, do you think A, Michael thinks the women will say this is a load of crap? Hey, he thinks the guys will go along with it. Why are there any women? Hmm, hmm, hmm.
珍娜，你有没有注意到这个场景的一个细节？它在会议室里，对吧？没错。对。都有谁出席了？谁？有吉姆、德怀特。吉姆、德怀特、托比、克里德、奥斯卡、瑞恩和斯坦利。一个女人都没有。嘿。嘿。现在，你认为A，迈克尔觉得女人们会认为这是胡扯吗？嘿，他觉得男人们会随声附和。为什么会有女人呢？嗯，嗯，嗯。
Jim convinces Michael that this is a pyramid scheme. Michael draws a chart and then Jim turns it into a literal pyramid. Do you remember in the fire episode when Michael said he lost all of his money in a pyramid scheme and that's why he couldn't go to business school? Yeah, Toby brings it up in this scene. Yeah, Toby's like, remember? Well, Toby brings up an email scam
吉姆说服迈克尔这是一个传销骗局。迈克尔画了一张图表，然后吉姆把它变成了一个真正的金字塔。你还记得在消防那一集里，迈克尔说他在一个传销骗局中输光了所有的钱，所以他才不能去商学院吗？对，托比在这个场景中提到了这件事。对，托比就像是在说，还记得吗？嗯，托比提到了一个电子邮件骗局
that Michael also participated in. Yes, and Michael's like, hey, when the son of the deposed King of Nigeria emails you directly asking you for help. Okay? Is fatherland the freaking country? Okay? Yeah. Michael. Michael. Michael. All right. So that's our cold open and then when the episode begins that was one of those standalone cold opens that did not end up applying. I have one more question about the cold open. You might know the answer. Oh, go ahead.
迈克尔也参与其中。是的，迈克尔说，嘿，当被废黜的尼日利亚国王的儿子直接发电子邮件向你求助时。好吧？祖国难道不是个国家吗？好吧？对。迈克尔。迈克尔。迈克尔。好吧。这就是我们的冷开场，然后当剧集开始时，那是那种没有实际关联的独立冷开场之一。关于冷开场我还有一个问题。你可能知道答案。哦，请说。
Is a calling card the same as a business card? What, Angela? What's a calling card? Wait, I know what a card is. You're not asking this question. Do you not remember the 80s? Honey, I was in, oh, I just called you honey. I'm a baby.
电话卡跟名片是一回事吗？什么，安吉拉？什么是电话卡？等等，我知道什么是卡。你不是在问这个问题吧。难道你不记得80年代了吗？亲爱的，我当时在……哦，我刚叫你亲爱的。我真是个小婴儿。
Honey. Honey, I was in Jakarta, Indonesia till 1984. What happened? What's the calling card? Okay. Gosh, how do I describe it? You know how long-distance phone calls they would cost money like so much money per minute if you wanted to call someone and you would usually just use your home phone and then
亲爱的。亲爱的，我直到1984年都一直在印度尼西亚雅加达。发生了什么？什么是电话卡？好吧。天哪，我该怎么形容呢？你知道长途电话费很贵，每分钟要花好多好多钱，如果你想给某人打电话，你通常只会用家里的电话，然后
I can't believe I'm describing this right now. Wait, so it was like a card with a number on it and you enter it or something and then you use the minutes. Yes, it's like a prepaid credit card that you could apply to the price of a phone call. Okay, I know what it is now. I got it. I remember that for whatever reason in my mind, I thought this whole scene was about business cards and I thought it was really funny. Oh, yeah That's funny. So anyway, and I was like, oh look they're making their own business cards. That's kind of cute. No No, you don't need fill in his corvette for that. Now this makes sense Yeah, okay. I hear the tone in your voice Jenna. I hear it. I don't know how to end this. I hear the tone in your voice, Jenna. I hear it. I hear it.
真不敢相信我正在描述这个。等等，所以它就像是一张带有号码的卡，你输入它或者别的什么，然后使用里面的分钟数？是的，它就像是一张可以抵扣电话费的预付费信用卡。好吧，我现在知道了。我懂了。我记得不知为什么，在我的脑海里，我以为整个场景都是关于名片的，我觉得这真的很好笑。哦，是的 很好笑。所以无论如何，当时我想，哦看，他们正在制作自己的名片。那挺可爱的。不 不，你不需要为此填满他的克尔维特跑车。现在这说得通了 是的，好吧。我听出了你语气里的情绪，珍娜。我听出来了。我不知道该怎么结束这个。我听出了你语气里的情绪，珍娜。我听出来了。我听出来了。
I hear it. I hear it. It's like you pity me, but you love me, but you're perplexed that a grown woman doesn't know what a calling card is. I hear it all. It's all there, but I love you. Okay. So they weren't business cards.
我听出来了。我听出来了。就好像你在同情我，但你又爱我，而且你感到很困惑，为什么一个成年女性居然不知道什么是电话卡。我都听出来了。全都在那儿，但我爱你。好吧。所以它们不是名片。
They were calling cards. All right. I love you, babe. I love you, babe. I love you, babe. I love you, honey. Go. That was the cold open. It was a standalone cold open, right? It doesn't apply to the rest of the episode because after the credits, we're going to learn the real platis episode when Michael enters and Pam, while handing him his messages for the day, says,
它们是电话卡。好吧。我爱你，宝贝。我爱你，宝贝。我爱你，宝贝。我爱你，亲爱的。走吧。那是冷开场。这是一个独立的冷开场，对吧？它跟本集的其余部分没有关系，因为片头过后，我们将了解本集的真正情节：迈克尔走进来，而帕姆在递给他一天的留言时说道，
happy birthday, Michael. And when he enters, he's carrying like his own box of donuts for his birthday. Is he carrying the balloons that we're gonna see later in his office? Probably. I couldn't, I couldn't track where the balloons came from. But then Michael has a talking head
生日快乐，迈克尔。当他进来时，他拿着一盒他自己买的甜甜圈来庆祝生日。他拿着我们稍后会在他办公室里看到的气球吗？可能吧。我没法，我没法追踪那些气球是从哪来的。但随后迈克尔有一个单人独白镜头
where he tells us that people go crazy for his birthday. They just go all out. They go all out. And it's just a boring shot of the office, just everyone doing work. Yeah. No one paying attention. And then, Junna, he says that he shares a birthday with Eva Lungoria.
他在镜头前告诉我们，大家为他的生日都快疯了。他们真的是全力以赴。他们真的是全力以赴。然而镜头里却是办公室无聊的画面，每个人都在干活。是的。根本没人理他。然后，珍娜，他说他跟伊娃·朗格利亚同一天生日。
And I looked up her birthday. It's March 15th. Jun Jenna years is March 7th. Yeah. That means you and Michael Scott are both Pisces! We're both Pisces. Which I also looked up. And this was what I found on the internet about Pisces. You, Jennifer, and Michael Scott, are you ready? I'm ready. In all matters of life, you bring intensity and passion. This explains why you will devote an endless amount of time and effort into anything that you feel is worthwhile, especially family and loved ones. Hey, I know. That sounds like a compliment. I think it is. You are giving me a compliment. I am giving you a compliment. Thank you. So now Jim has a talking head. Well wait, wait, wait, before we get to that,
我查了她的生日。是3月15日。珍娜，你的是3月7日。耶。这意味着你和迈克尔·斯科特都是双鱼座！我们都是双鱼座。我也查了一下。以下是我在网上查到的关于双鱼座的内容。你，詹妮弗，还有迈克尔·斯科特，准备好了吗？我准备好了。在生活的方方面面，你都倾注了强度与激情。这解释了为什么你会将无穷的时间和精力投入到任何你认为有价值的事情中，尤其是家庭和挚爱。嘿，我知道。这听起来像是个夸奖。我想是的。你是在夸我。我是在夸你。谢谢。那么现在吉姆有一个单人镜头。等等，等等，在我们讲到那个之前，
I think something really important happens here, which is Kevin is late for work. Now we don't know why yet, but he's late. He seems a little preoccupied. And when he walks in, Michael's like, you're late, but you're forgiven because Doth that is my birthday. This has made me laugh.
我觉得这里发生了一件非常重要的事情，那就是凯文上班迟到了。现在我们还不知道原因，但他确实迟到了。他看起来有点心神不定。当他走进来时，迈克尔说，你迟到了，但你被原谅了，因为毕竟那是我的生日。这把我逗笑了。
Michael's such an idiot. I love him. But yes, Kevin is late. So, and then we go to Jim's talking head. Well, here's something I want to say about Jim's talking head. So the meat of the talking head is he's just kind of describing what Michael is like
迈克尔真是个笨蛋。我爱他。不过是的，凯文迟到了。所以，然后我们转到吉姆的单人独白。好吧，关于吉姆的单人独白，我想说的是。这个单人独白的实质就是他在描述迈克尔是个什么样的人
on his birthday, but look at the winter backdrop behind him. So you know what we, that's, you know what we love this, you love this. You know I love our backdrops. Okay, so that's not a real window to the outside. That's just a window to a printed backdrop that we would change seasonally. And I just noticed that the backdrop is winter. It looks like it's maybe snowy
在他生日那天，但看看他身后的冬日背景。所以你知道我们，那是，你知道我们爱这个，你爱这个。你知道我爱我们的背景。好吧，所以那不是通往外面的真正的窗户。那只是一扇通往印有背景的窗户，我们会根据季节更换。我刚注意到背景是冬天的。看起来可能是下雪了
and I'm gonna bring this up later. So put a pin in that, but I just want to say winter backdrop behind Jim. I am riveted. I am riveted. I cannot wait. Oh, it's going to pay off later. I cannot wait for this pay off time of the winter backdrop. All right. So then we see Meredith and Kevin in the break room and she says, did you hear anything yet? And so we start to see like what's happening with Kevin, right? That he might have a skin cancer scare.
我待会儿会提到这个。所以先把这个放在一边，但我只想说吉姆身后的冬日背景。我被迷住了。我被迷住了。我等不及了。哦，这会在后面有回报的。我等不及冬日背景的这个回报时刻了。好吧。然后我们看到梅雷迪思和凯文在休息室，她说，你听到什么消息了吗？于是我们开始看到凯文身上发生了什么，对吧？他可能面临皮肤癌的恐慌。
Yeah. And this storyline starts. And then we go to Dwight and Michael's office. There is no one more excited for Michael's birthday than Dwight. Really? I mean, it is such a special day for him. It is a huge day. If only everyone were reacting like Dwight, Michael would be happy. Michael reveals he's wearing a new suit.
是的。这条故事线开始了。然后我们去德怀特和迈克尔的办公室。没有人比德怀特更对迈克尔的生日感到兴奋了。真的吗？我的意思是，这对他是如此特殊的一天。这是重要的一天。要不是每个人都像德怀特那样反应，迈克尔就会很高兴。迈克尔透露他穿着一件新西装。
He says it's from Italy. No, Bulgaria. Right. New suit. And Dwight said maybe he'll have to get one and Michael's like, good luck. It's pinstriped, I noticed. And the tie is insane.
他说那是从意大利买的。不，保加利亚。对吧。新西装。德怀特说也许他也得买一件，迈克尔说，祝你好运。我注意到是细条纹的。领带也很疯狂。
It's a crazy tie as well. This is also the scene where Michael tells Dwight that he's not worried about his birthday because the PPC has been working 24, seven since yesterday. But also, it's in the scene that Dwight actually begs Michael if he can be in charge of Michael's birthday. So this is setting up like what's going to be a big source of tension between Angela and Dwight.
这也是一条疯狂的领带。这也是迈克尔告诉德怀特他并不担心自己的生日，因为派对策划委员会从昨天开始就一直在全天候24/7工作的场景。但也是在这个场景中，德怀特实际上恳求迈克尔让他负责迈克尔的生日。所以这为安吉拉和德怀特之间将成为巨大紧张来源的事情做了铺垫。
And I think Angela thinks that Michael's an idiot and thinks that Dwight is loyal to someone who doesn't deserve like his loyalty. And so she's just are ready. She already is like annoyed that it's Michael's birthday. And now on top of the fact her boyfriend wants to be the party planning committee chairman. Well, Angela must be very conflicted because as party planning committee head,
而且我认为安吉拉认为迈克尔是个白痴，并认为德怀特忠于一个不配得到他忠诚的人。所以她已经准备好了。她已经因为今天是迈克尔的生日而感到恼火了。现在再加上她的男朋友想当派对策划委员会主席的事。好吧，安吉拉一定非常矛盾，因为作为派对策划委员会负责人，
she is obligated to celebrate this birthday. Yes, yes. Even though she feels that Michael is kind of going a little bit over the top, right? Mm-hmm. Yes. Well, Ange, the next scene is the party planning committee scene. One more thing before we move on, there is a famous meme that came out of this Dwighten Michael scene. It is La Rue de Ruef.
她有义务庆祝这个生日。是的，是的。尽管她觉得迈克尔有点做得有点过头了，对吧？嗯哼。是的。好吧，安吉，下一个场景是派对策划委员会的场景。在我们继续之前还有一件事，这个德怀特和迈克尔的场景中出了一个著名的表情包。那是 La Rue de Ruef。
Oh, the Rue de Ruef, yes. Yes. Yes. And in the super famous meme, it's even longer in the deleted scenes you guys So if you check out the deleted scenes, it's really funny because when Dwight starts to do it Michael's like no That's not how I taught you I should like like clearly they've practiced this move. Oh, I love that I love that there's an extra deleted scene of that raised the roof. Well next up is the party planning committee meeting lady It's the OG. it's the OG.
哦，Rue de Ruef，是的。是的。是的。在那个超级著名的表情包里，在你们的删减片段中它甚至更长。所以如果你看看删减片段，真的很好笑，因为当德怀特开始做那个动作时，迈克尔说，不，这不是我教你的。我应该像……显然他们练习过这个动作。哦，我喜欢那个，我喜欢还有一个关于那个“抬高屋顶”动作的额外删减片段。好吧，接下来是派对策划委员会会议，女士。它是元老。它是元老。
It's the OG. It is Phyllis, Angela, and Pam. That's it. Baby, I don't know what... Do you call me Baby? Oh, G is. I did. That's what it is today.
它是元老。那是菲利斯、安吉拉和帕姆。就这样。宝贝，我不知道……你叫我宝贝吗？哦，G是。我叫了。今天就是这样的。
OG. Jenna. Okay, get on the internet, lady. What is it? You might know what a calling card is, but let me tell you what OG is. It means original gangster. Original gangster. It's original gangster, original gangster.
元老。詹娜。好吧，上网上查查，女士。那是什么？你可能知道什么是名片，但让我告诉你什么是元老。它的意思是地道黑帮。地道黑帮。是地道黑帮，地道黑帮。
It's like you are the first person of this thing, whatever. I don't know. Look it up on Urban Dictionary. So it's the OG of the PPC. Of the PPC. Mm-hmm. Oh, I want a hoodie that says OG of the PPC. Nope.
就像你是这件事的第一个人，随便啦。我不知道。在城市词典上查一下。所以它是派对策划委员会的元老。派对策划委员会的。嗯哼。哦，我想要一件写着派对策划委员会元老的连帽衫。不。
That would be great. Oh, look at the coffee mug I'm using. I'm using the OG PPC. You're, look at the coffee mug I'm using. I'm using the OGPPC. Oh, you're using the OGPPC coffee mug today. Yay. That's apropos. That's another word, Angela, apropos. I know what that means.
那会很棒。哦，看看我用的咖啡杯。我用的是元老派对策划委员会的。你，看看我用的咖啡杯。我用的是元老派对策划委员会的。哦，你今天用的是元老派对策划委员会的咖啡杯。耶。这很贴切。那是另一个词，安吉拉，贴切。我知道那是什么意思。
It means appropriate. Yeah, I got it. Okay. All right, so they're having a riveting conversation in this meeting, they wanna know what time we should bring out the cake. One at one thirty. Pam Yons.
意思是恰当。是的，我懂了。好吧。好吧，他们在这次会议上进行着引人入胜的对话，他们想知道我们应该什么时候把蛋糕端出来。一点半。帕姆打哈欠。
Oh wait, Pam Yons. Pam says one o'clock to which Angela immediately says one thirty, and then Pam Yons. Yeah, and then Angela sasses her. Yeah, she's like, oh, I'm sorry. Are we boring you? Well, you know, there's in a deleted scene, I improvised a line where I said not Phyllis. Yes. Do you remember that? I do. I do. And then we all laughed. We used to laugh a lot when we did these PPC scenes. Well, they would let us go. They would give us a few
哦等等，帕姆打哈欠。帕姆说一点钟，安吉拉立刻说一点半，然后帕姆打哈欠。是的，然后安吉拉对她冷嘲热讽。是的，她就像是，哦，我很抱歉。我们让你觉得无聊了吗？好吧，你知道，在一个删减片段中，我即兴说了一句台词，我说除了菲利斯。是的。你记得吗？我记得。我记得。然后我们都笑了。我们以前拍这些派对策划委员会的场景时经常笑。好吧，他们会让我们自由发挥。他们会给我们几个
lines and then they would just let us go. And we would improvise the most boring conversations on purpose. We'd be like, well, I don't know guys how I feel about paper plates. I mean, which size should we get? Should we get the large oval one? No one gets oval. Who gets an oval paper plate? No one. I think we get the square one, square paper plates.
台词，然后就让我们自由发挥。我们会故意即兴发挥最无聊的对话。我们会说，嗯，我不知道大家我对纸盘有什么感觉。我的意思是，我们应该买多大尺寸的？我们应该买大椭圆形的吗？没有人买椭圆形的。谁会买椭圆形纸盘？没有人。我想我们应该买正方形的，正方形纸盘。
We would do this for like so long. That's because Greg Daniels loved the PPC. I love. He loved our mundane banter so much. He loved the dynamic of it. And so he would let us just go on forever. I loved it. Yes, it was so fun.
我们可以这样做很久。那是因为格雷格·丹尼尔斯热爱派对策划委员会。我爱。他太喜欢我们那些平凡的闲聊了。他喜欢那种动态。所以他会让我们一直说下去。我爱极了。是的，太有趣了。
Well then Dwight enters and he tells us that Michael wants trick candles for his cake. Yeah, he gives us a list, a list of surprises that Michael would like. And this is when Angela tells Dwight that this is a closed door meeting. Well, yeah, Michael wants trick candles. He wants a stripper, Graham. And Angela's like, no, no, it's a closed door meeting. And then there's this sort of odd like stare-off between Dwight and Angela, and Pam was like, what is happening?
然后德怀特进来了，他告诉我们迈克尔想要在他的蛋糕上用魔术蜡烛。是的，他给我们列了个清单，列出了迈克尔想要的惊喜清单。这时候安吉拉告诉德怀特这是一场闭门会议。好吧，是的，迈克尔想要魔术蜡烛。他想要一个脱衣舞男格雷厄姆。安吉拉说，不，不，这是一场闭门会议。然后德怀特和安吉拉之间有一种奇怪的对视，帕姆说，发生什么事了？
Yes. I have a fan catch as well. What? This is a fan catch from sexually woke. This person wrote in to say, Phyllis is breaking at four minutes, 19 seconds, when you talk about the strip of Graham. I did not notice this the first time I watched it. And I
是的。我也有一个粉丝发现。什么？这是来自“性感觉醒”的粉丝发现。这个人写信说，菲利斯在4分19秒时笑场了，当时你们在谈论脱衣舞男格雷厄姆。我第一次看的时候没有注意到这个。我
saw it. She gets a little smirk. And I think you could think it was Phyllis the character, but Angela, we know Phyllis. And I think this was a real Phyllis smile. I'm sure it was. We laughed a lot in those scenes. So I love that. I'm going to go back and look for that. That's so that. I'm going to go back and look for that. That's so cute. I also want to note that when rain comes in and out of the door, John is not at his desk in the background.
看到了。她露出一丝微笑。我想你可能会以为那是角色菲利斯，但安吉拉，我们了解菲利斯。我认为这是一个真正的菲利斯的微笑。我敢肯定是。我们在那些场景里笑了很多。所以我很喜欢那个。我要回去找找看。太可爱了。我还想指出的是，当雷恩进出门口时，背景中的约翰不在他的办公桌前。
So he bailed on some background work. Way to go, John. Way to be sneaky and get out of that scene. I know. I guess what was he, he was probably playing Madden football in his trailer with Brian. Yes, there was nothing that they would do in their downtime when Brian. Yes, they were playing Madden football. They were playing Madden football. And they were down time when they had scenes.
所以他逃掉了一些背景工作。干得好，约翰。真狡猾，逃掉了那个场景。我知道。我猜他当时在干嘛，他可能在和布赖恩一起在他的房车里玩疯狂橄榄球游戏。是的，当布赖恩在的时候，他们在闲暇时间什么都不做。是的，他们在玩疯狂橄榄球。他们在玩疯狂橄榄球。那是他们有场景时的闲暇时间。
And they would yell. They were so loud. Do you remember? They were so loud. They'd be like, get it. Get them. All right, so at four minutes, 35 seconds, we now have this phone call between Michael and Jan
他们会大喊大叫。他们声音太大了。你还记得吗？他们声音太大了。他们会说，抓住它。抓住他们。好吧，在4分35秒时，现在迈克尔和简之间有了这个电话，
and Michael's office. Yeah. And Jenna, did you catch who is in the room with Michael Ryan? Ryan is sitting there for the whole phone call and the call is so awkward. He's like, hey, I Called to wish you happy birthday and she's like, it's not my birthday And he's like, oh, I thought we had the same birthday and she's like no and then she's like happy birthday Michael And then she's like are we being filmed and he's like, nope not, Michael. And then she's like, are we being filmed? And he's like, nope, not at all. And then he says, Jan, just feel free to say whatever is in your heart.
在迈克尔的办公室里。是的。詹娜，你发现谁和迈克尔在同一个房间里了吗？瑞安。瑞安整个通话过程都坐在那里，这个电话太尴尬了。他说，嘿，我打电话祝你生日快乐，她说，这不是我的生日，他说，哦，我以为我们同一天生日，她说，不是，然后她说，生日快乐，迈克尔，然后她说，我们在被拍摄吗？他说，没有，完全没有，迈克尔。然后她说，我们在被拍摄吗？他说，没有，完全没有。然后他说，简，随时说出你心里的话。
And then doesn't she just like hang up? Click, dial tone. And the whole time Ryan is sitting here. And I have a little something to point out. If you go and watch the deleted scenes, there is a beginning to this scene. And that is that Ryan the temp has been given the task to tie those balloons in Michael's office.
然后她是不是直接就挂断了？咔哒，拨号音。而瑞安一直坐在那儿。我有一点要指出。如果你去看删减片段，这个场景有一个开头。那就是临时工瑞安被派去把那些气球系在迈克尔的办公室里。
And so- Oh, this is where the balloons come from. Yes. So him and Michael are in his office. Ryan is tying a balloon to like his chair. And then he's like, can I leave? And Michael's like, nope. Thank you so much for telling me this. because I was wondering where did those dang balloons
所以——哦，气球就是这么来的。是的。所以他和迈克尔在办公室里。瑞安正把一个气球系在他的椅子上。然后他说，我可以离开吗？迈克尔说，不行。非常感谢你告诉我这个，
come from because Michael did not walk in with them. He must have somehow ordered Ryan the temp to get them. Yes. And then he makes him see as the proof. He makes some stay in for the phone call. Oh, God. That's so miserable. I feel so bad for Ryan in that scene. Well, the next scene is very miserable. I feel so bad for writing that scene. Well, the next scene is very cringy as well because Michael's in the kitchen and he is just hovering over this box of donuts waiting for someone. And then when Stanley comes in, he's like, Oh my gosh, somebody must have brought in donuts for my birthday. Michael,
因为我一直在想那些该死的汽球是从哪儿来的，因为迈克尔走进来时并没有带它们。他一定是通过某种方式命令临时工瑞安去弄来的。是的。然后他让他看着作为证据。他让一些人留下来接听电话。哦，天哪。太悲惨了。在这个场景里我真为瑞安感到难过。好吧，下一个场景非常悲惨。我真为写那个场景感到难过。好吧，下一个场景也非常尴尬，因为迈克尔在厨房里，他一直在那盒甜甜圈旁边徘徊，等待着某人。然后当斯坦利进来时，他说，哦天哪，肯定有人为了我的生日带了甜甜圈来。迈克尔，
we saw you carry that box in when you arrived. Michael. Somebody. Michael. Michael. Michael. Michael. I have something to point out here.
我们看到你来的时候搬着那个盒子。迈克尔。某人。迈克尔。迈克尔。迈克尔。我这里有一点要指出。
So you know in Boos Crews, you and Jim look at each other for 27 seconds of silence, right? Yeah. 27 seconds. Is that right? 27 seconds. That's right. Okay. I want you to know how long Michael stood
所以你知道在《游轮派对》里，你和吉姆在27秒的沉默中互相对视，对吧？是的。27秒。是这样吗？27秒。没错。好的。我想让你知道迈克尔站了多久，
with his hand on that coffee pot, waiting for someone to come in. So he could act like he was putting himself a cup of coffee, act surprised, there were donuts for his birthday. He stood there for 10 seconds of pure silence. Wow. Now if you think about a TV show, you guys,
他的手放在那个咖啡壶上，等着有人进来。这样他就可以假装给自己倒杯咖啡，假装惊讶，有人为了他的生日准备了甜甜圈。他在纯粹的沉默中站了10秒钟。哇。现在如果你想想一部电视剧，伙计们，
that's like a long time to leave a character just sitting there waiting for someone to notice him. That is so true. That's amazing. 10 seconds. 10 seconds, he stood there looking around, waiting for someone to walk in. And then later when Toby comes in, it's so sad. Toby sees the donuts and he finds out it's Michael's birthday and he gives
让一个角色坐在那里等着别人注意到他，这算是很长的时间了。确实如此。太神奇了。10秒钟。他站在那里环顾四周，等着有人走进来，这持续了10秒钟。后来托比进来时，太让人难过了。托比看到了甜甜圈，他发现今天是迈克尔的生日，他给出了
the most just upbeat genuine, genuine happy birthday Michael. Yeah. And then Michael is so mean. Michael's like, you didn't remember? Yeah, I guess I'm not going to remember to give you a donut. Yeah, I guess I'm not going to remember to give you a donut. I know. He's such a turd to Toby and Toby was being so nice to him. I know. So also happening in this episode is everyone kind of learning about the fact that Kevin's waiting for these skin test results. So like gyms and the in the break room and they're talking about it and Kelly over here. Yeah. Kelly, you mean Mindy. Mindy over here. That is a Mindy Kaling talking head. When she's like, oh my gosh, I never thought about death until Princess Diana's funeral, which was so sad. And then she pauses and she's like, that and my sisters, like, oh, it's such a dark,
最真诚、最由衷的“生日快乐，迈克尔”。是的。然后迈克尔太刻薄了。迈克尔说，你没记住？对，我想我也不会记得给你一个甜甜圈。对，我想我也不会记得给你一个甜甜圈。我知道。他对托比太混蛋了，而托比对他是那么好。我知道。这一集中还发生的事是，大家差不多都知道了凯文在等待皮肤测试结果。所以吉姆在休息室里，他们在谈论这件事，凯利也在旁边。是的。凯利，我是说明迪。明迪在这边。那是明迪·卡灵的访谈。当她说，哦天哪，我从没想过死亡，直到戴安娜王妃的葬礼，太令人悲伤了。然后她停顿了一下，她说，还有我姐姐们的，就像，哦，这是一个多么黑暗的，
it's such a dark talking head. It's so dark. I don't know how many got through that. She almost didn't. I want you to know Look at six minutes five seconds. Mindy is so about to laugh. She's barely holding it together Well, then the accounting department is discussing Kevin's possible skin cancer, Angela. And you are, I mean, Angela Martin is a real downer. She's a little bit of Debbie Downer. I mean, Oscar's like, you know what? I'm sure it's going to be fine. I'm like, don't give him false hope. You don't know that.
这是一个多么黑暗的访谈。太黑暗了。我不知道有多少人能挺过那个。她差点没忍住。我想让你们知道，看6分05秒。明迪快要笑出来了。她快要憋不住了。好吧，然后会计部门在讨论凯文可能患有皮肤癌，安吉拉。你是说，我是说安吉拉·马丁真是个扫兴鬼。她有点像扫兴鬼黛比。我是说，奥斯卡说，你知道吗？我确信会没事的。我说，别给他虚假的希望。你并不知道。
Is that pragmatic? I think she is, you know, I, yeah, she's pragmatic. She doesn't need to see the rosy picture. She's like just give me the stats Yeah, what are the stats on this the stats are you should be worried? Yeah That's what the stats say so next up Michael gets a delivery Oh, man, he thinks that the woman is his strip a gram. He's so excited. He's giddy He literally says here here we go.
这算务实吗？我认为她是，你知道，我，是的，她是务实的。她不需要看到美好的前景。她就像是，直接把统计数据告诉我吧。是的，关于这个的统计数据是什么？统计数据是你应该担心。是的。这就是统计数据所说的。所以接下来，迈克尔收到了一个快递。哦，天哪，他以为那个女人是他的脱衣舞男。他太兴奋了。他欣喜若狂。他 literalmente 说，来，来，我们开始吧。
And then he has a line that made me laugh so hard. He's like, oh, this chair has arms. Is that gonna be all right? I love that line. That made me laugh so hard. He's like, it'll be fine. I don't know. You'll work around it.
然后他有一句台词让我笑得前仰后合。他说，哦，这把椅子有扶手。这没问题吧？我喜欢那句台词。那让我笑得太厉害了。他说，会没事的。我不知道。你会克服它的。
I think Steve improvised that. I feel like he improvised that. I don't know. I don't know. I bet you're right. I do. I wish I had the script for this one because I would look it up, but I feel like that feels like,
我想那是史蒂夫即兴发挥的。我觉得那是他即兴发挥的。我不知道。我不知道。我敢打赌你是对的。是的。我希望我有这一集的剧本，因为我会去查一下，但我觉得那感觉像，
that feels like something you notice in the moment. Right, because they just pulled the chair side and it had arms and I think he saw it at the moment and he said it, that's what I, it feels very much like a Steve Improv moment. Well, I do wanna just give a shout out to this guest actor Susan Foley, who played the delivery woman I thought she was great.
那感觉像是你在那一刻注意到的东西。对，因为他们刚把椅子拉到旁边，它有扶手，我想他当时看到了就说了出来，这就是我所认为的，这非常像史蒂夫即兴发挥的时刻。好吧，我只想向这位客座演员苏珊·弗利致敬，她扮演了送货员，我觉得她演得很好。
She was fantastic. She played it super straight, super real, made it very, very funny. Her confusion was not overplayed. It was perfection. Yeah. Well done, Susan. And then we just find out some sad backstory of Michael's childhood. Jenna, his childhood breaks my heart.
她太棒了。她演得非常正经，非常真实，非常非常搞笑。她的困惑并没有表现过头。简直是完美。干得好，苏珊。然后我们了解到了迈克尔童年的一些悲惨背景故事。詹娜，他的童年让我心碎。
It breaks my heart. So we have this birthday party when he was seven. He was so excited. He said they got a pony and a cart and the pony gave him a rash and his mom rubbed him on him for three hours. And then he missed the party. He said it was his worst birthday. Well, this is a runner and some of them got cut out,
让我心碎。所以我们有他七岁时的生日派对。他太兴奋了。他说他们得到了一匹小马和一辆手推车，小马让他长了皮疹，他妈妈在他身上揉了三个小时。然后他错过了派对。他说那是他最糟糕的生日。好吧，这是一个贯穿全剧的笑话，虽然有些被剪掉了，
but Michael had this runner throughout this episode of all of his worst birthdays, comparing it to this one. So this guy has had a lot of bad birthdays. Well, he's gonna get a pick me up from Dwight who's gonna play the recorder for him while he eats donuts. Dwight is playing Billy Joel,
但迈克尔在这一整集中都有这个关于他所有最糟糕生日的笑话，并把它和这次作比较。所以这家伙经历过很多糟糕的生日。好吧，他会从德怀特那里得到一点精神振奋，德怀特会一边吃甜甜圈一边为他吹竖笛。德怀特吹的是比利·乔尔的歌，
which is a runner on our show. We're constantly going to the Billy Joel music library on the office. I don't know why that is. For the longest time. Ha. Of course, Dwight calls him William Joel. And then Michael is just sort of lamenting
这也是我们节目中的一个梗。我们一直在《办公室》里使用比利·乔尔的音乐库。我不知道为什么会这样。持续了很长时间。哈。当然，德怀特叫他威廉·乔尔。然后迈克尔只是在哀叹
how he's being treated in the office. And he says, I bet Luke Perry's friends don't treat him like this. Wait. And he references this poster that this is what the delivery woman was delivering. It is a poster of James Dean, not of Luke Perry, that his mom sent him for his birthday. That's what his mom sent him. Now, do you think that his mom meant to send him Luke Perry?
他在办公室里是如何被对待的。他说，我敢打赌卢克·佩里的朋友不会这样对待他。等等。他提到了送货员送来的那张海报。那是一张詹姆斯·迪恩的海报，而不是卢克·佩里的海报，那是他妈妈寄给他的生日礼物。那是他妈妈寄给他的。现在，你觉得他妈妈是故意送他卢克·佩里吗？
Or she meant to send him James Dean and Michael just mistook it for Luke Perry, which one is Michael a fan of? Or neither? Is it just Michael's mom was like, I don't know what to give him? I think Michael's probably a fan of Luke Perry, and that's who his mom thought it was.
还是她本打算送他詹姆斯·迪恩，而迈克尔误把它当成了卢克·佩里，迈克尔到底是哪一个的粉丝？还是都不是？只是迈克尔的妈妈觉得，我不知道该送他什么？我想迈克尔可能是卢克·佩里的粉丝，他妈妈就是这么认为的。
That's what I think. I think. I like that story. I don't know, but I mean, I feel like that's something my mom would do. Or my sister. When you're at Christmas, my sister got me a green Bay Packers baseball hat.
我是这么想的。我想。我喜欢那个故事。我不知道，但我的意思是，我觉得那是我妈妈会做的事。或者我姐姐。当你在过圣诞节时，我姐姐送了我一顶绿湾包装工队的棒球帽。
Yeah. And I was like, I don't get it. And she was like, well, you went to Baylor, green and gold. Same colors. I was like, what? Same colors. Right.
是的。我说，我不明白。她说，哦，你去了贝勒大学，绿色和金色。颜色一样。我说，什么？颜色一样。对。
Same colors. So I feel like that could be sort of a mom moment. Angela, one year for Christmas, my mom got me from, I guess, a local art fair in St. Louis, a drawing of a woman and her cat. Mm-hmm. She got it for me because she knows I love cats. I'm gonna post this on office lady's pod Instagram. Is she gonna get upset with you? Is she gonna say something? No, this is a running joke in our family now. It is Angela, it is a, it is a, I don't know how to describe it.
颜色一样。所以我觉得这有点像妈妈的时刻。安吉拉，有一年的圣诞节，我妈妈从圣路易斯的一个本地艺术集市上给我买了一幅画，画的是一个女人和她的猫。嗯哼。她买给是因为她知道我喜欢猫。我要把它发到办公室女士们的播客Instagram上。她会生你的气吗？她会说些什么吗？不，这现在成了我们家里的一个老笑话了。安吉拉，这是一个，这是一个，我不知道怎么形容。
It is a drawing of a woman on all fours. What? In lingerie. No. With her touch on the air. She is the drawing of a woman on all fours. What? In lingerie. Nope. With her touch on the air. No. And the cat is rubbing seductively on the woman's tush. Hey, your mom missed all that.
这是一幅画，画的是一个四肢着地的女人。什么？穿着内衣。没有。把她的屁股翘在空中。她是一幅画，画的是一个四肢着地的女人。什么？穿着内衣。没有。把她的屁股翘在空中。没有。而那只猫正在挑逗地蹭着那个女人的屁股。嘿，你妈妈漏掉了所有这些。
She just thought it was a lady in her cat. Yes. So, Angela, imagine me on Christmas morning. She hands me, I'm in like college when she gives me this. I come home from college, I unwrap this box and I'm looking at like a semi-pornographic drawing of a woman in her cat. It's like, mom, what is this present?
她以为那只是一位女士和她的猫。是的。所以，安吉拉，想象一下圣诞节早上的我。她递给我，我大概在上大学时她送我的。我从大学回家，我打开这个盒子，我看到的是一幅半色情的女人和她的猫的画。我说，妈妈，这是什么礼物？
She goes, what do you mean? It's a lady who looks her cat. She loves what she's saying so much. She's like, she loves, you love cats. And I'm like, Bob, I do love cats, but what is happening? And she still like, didn't see it. She's like, I don't get it. My sister died laughing.
她说，你什么意思？这是一位女士看着她的猫。她太喜欢她所说的话了。她说，她喜欢，你喜欢猫。我说，妈，我确实喜欢猫，但这到底是怎么回事？她还是没看出来。她说，我不明白。我姐姐笑得前仰后合。
I don't know if we've ever laughed so hard on Christmas ever in my family. So now, here's, I still have it. Where is it? I'll tell you, I keep it in a drawer, but every time my parents come to my house and stay in my guest room, I get it out and I put it on the nightstand.
我不知道我们家里有没有在圣诞节笑得这么厉害过。所以现在，这里，我依然留着它。它在哪儿？我告诉你，我把它放在一个抽屉里，但每当我的父母来到我家并住在我的客房时，我把它拿出来放在床头柜上。
And then there it is. And I'm like, mom, you're a gift gave me. And she knows that I do that. She knows that I don't keep it out all the time. But I like religiously, I put it out whenever they visit. I and I will post a picture of it. I will post a picture of it. I love that story so much. I love it so much. That is something that's 100% that my dad would do. I have a story I will say for another one that my dad bought a painting from a man on the side of the road.
然后它就在那儿。我说，妈妈，这是你送的礼物。她知道我那样做。她知道我不是一直把它摆在外面。但我像仪式一样，每当他们来访时我都会把它摆出来。我会发一张它的照片。我会发一张它的照片。我太喜欢那个故事了。我太喜欢了。那百分之百是我爸爸会做的事。我还有一个故事，我留着以后讲，我爸爸从路边一个人那里买了一幅画。
I'm gonna save it. Oh, oh. It was a Valentine's gift. I'm gonna save it. Okay, where are we? Where are we? Dwight goes into the bullpen and he announces that it is 1123 AM the exact time of Michael's birth and he suggests that everyone lift him up in his chair. Yes,
我要留着它。哦，哦。那是情人节礼物。我要留着它。好吧，我们在哪儿？我们在哪儿？德怀特走进办公区，宣布现在是上午11点23分，也就是迈克尔出生的确切时间，他建议大家把迈克尔连同椅子一起抬起来。是的
it's a tradition. They're gonna hoist him up in the air. It's a tradition. Well, I caught something here. What? I want you to look at Phyllis in the background of this scene. At the very beginning of the scene, she is behind Dwight at her computer. And I think that they said action before she had a chance to clear her computer screen. Is it Gates? Because she looking at Gates? I don't know, because she did go on a long, deep dive where she would look for Gates for a long time, a gate for her driveway. I don't know.
这是一个传统。他们要把他抬到空中。这是一个传统。好吧，我这里发现了点东西。什么？我想让你看这个场景背景里的菲利斯。在这个场景一开始，她就在德怀特身后的电脑前。我想他们还没等她关掉电脑屏幕就喊了开始。是盖茨吗？因为她在看盖茨？我不知道，因为她确实经历了一段漫长而深入的搜索过程，找了好长时间的盖茨，为她车道找个大门。我不知道。
I really tried to zoom in and see what it was, but what you have to see is that right at the top of the scene, she puts her hand up to cover up whatever is on her screen. And then at eight minutes, 53 seconds, when Michael comes out of his office, it's like a, it's a continuous shot when you come back to Phyllis,
我真的很努力地放大想看看那是什么，但你必须注意到的是，就在镜头刚切到这个场景时，她把手抬起来挡住了屏幕上的内容。然后在8分53秒时，迈克尔从办公室出来，当你镜头切回菲利斯时，这是一个连续的镜头，
the Dunder Mifflin screensaver is up. Oh, she was quick. She was quick. Yeah, she puts her hand up and with her left hand, she's like closing out of whatever she was doing. I have such a vivid memory of our camera guys, Randall or Matt saying, hey, Phyllis, we can see the gates on your screen.
邓德米夫林的屏息保护程序出来了。哦，她手真快。她真快。对，她抬起手用左手关掉了她刚才在做的事情。我对我们的摄像师兰德尔或马特有一段非常生动的记忆，他们说，嘿，菲利斯，我们能看到你屏幕上的大门。
Cause like for a year, she looked at gates for her driveway. Aw, that makes me laugh. Well, it's at this point that Pam and Jim are in the kitchen. They are not participating in the hoisting of Michael. And Pam suggests to Jim that they sneak out and buy something for Kevin. Yeah. At 10 minutes, 33 seconds, you guys. We learn who Dwight tips and who he doesn't.
因为她找车道的大门找了一年左右。哦，这让我笑死了。好吧，就在这个时候，帕姆和吉姆在厨房里。他们没有参与把迈克尔抬起来的活动。帕姆向吉姆建议，他们可以溜出去为凯文买点东西。对。在10分33秒时，大家。我们知道了德怀特会给谁小费，不会给谁小费。
And let me tell you, he tips his urologist. He can't pulverize his own kidney stones. And he only tips people who do jobs that he couldn't do himself. So when the sub delivery guy who was played by Justin Maloney, by the way, delivers a bunch of sub sandwiches, Dwight gives him exact change because he could have delivered his own subs. He could have.
我告诉你们吧，他给他的泌尿科医生小费。他自己没办法粉碎肾结石。而且他只给那些做他自己做不了的工作的人小费。所以当顺便说一句由贾斯汀·马洛尼扮演的三明治外卖员送来一堆三明治时，德怀特给他的都是正好的零钱，因为他本可以自己去送三明治的。他完全可以。
He didn't, but he could have. And then in the break room, we find out that these sub sandwiches are baloney, tomato, and ketchup. Yes. That's it. There's no other options. It's baloney, tomato, and ketchup.
他没去，但他本可以。然后在休息室里，我们发现这些三明治是博洛尼亚香肠、西红柿和番茄酱。是的。就是这样。没有别的选择了。就是博洛尼亚香肠、西红柿和番茄酱。
What is that? Angela, we have a fan question. This is a fan question from Old Man David. Okay, he wanted to know, did any of you guys actually eat any of that horrible subsanwich? I was at right aid. Do you remember, did anyone eat them
那是什么？安吉拉，我们有一个粉丝提问。这是一个来自老大卫的粉丝提问。好的，他想知道，你们当中有人真的吃过那些可怕的三明治吗？我在莱德药妆店。你还记得吗，有人吃过它们吗
and were they actually baloney and ketchup? Old man David, whatever those sandwiches were, were maybe set out by craft services and people could maybe snack on them. But I don't remember the cast or crew eating them, but they never let things go to waste. If they had food that was in a scene that was edible, they would set it out over by where all the snacks were,
而且它们真的是博洛尼亚香肠加番茄酱吗？老大卫，不管那些三明治是什么，可能是后勤服务部门摆在那里的，大家可能随便吃了一点。但我不记得演员或剧组人员吃过它们，不过他们从不浪费东西。如果他们在某个场景中有可以吃的食物，他们会把它摆在所有零食旁边，
anything that wasn't used, or they would give them to crew members. So like, if we had a scene where we had a bunch of birthday cakes, if they didn't use those birthday cakes, they would give them to people to take home. That's true. Maybe we set them out and who knows what they really were. We don't know.
任何没有用完的东西，或者他们会送给剧组人员。所以，如果我们有一场戏有很多生日蛋糕，如果他们没用完那些生日蛋糕，他们就会把蛋糕送给大伙带回家。确实如此。也许我们把它们摆出来了，谁知道它们到底是什么呢。我们不知道。
Yeah, maybe they were normal sandwiches, but my character, Kabash, is anyone eating because she's got a really crappy attitude about these sandwiches and she just makes Michael really mad and he packs them up and he's like, fine, choke on it and he walks right up and he's like, fine, choke on it and he walks right out. Well, then Angela, we have another one of Michael's sad birthday talking heads about his childhood.
对，也许它们是正常的三明治，但我的角色卡巴什，有人在吃吗，因为她对这些三明治态度极其糟糕，她把迈克尔气得够呛，迈克尔把它们打包好，然后说，好吧，噎死你算了，他径直走过去说，好吧，噎死你算了，然后直接气冲冲地走了。好吧，安吉拉，我们还有迈克尔关于他童年的另一个悲伤的单人采访。
This time he talks about being 16 years old and how he was supposed to go out on a date with a classmate named Julie, but she went out with a different Michael from his class instead because she didn't realize which Michael she was supposed to go out with. He just has had a whole, yeah. Here's an interesting catch, Angela, in this talking head, he says he had to hear all about it the next day at school. Well, you mentioned that his birthday was March 15th.
这次他谈到自己16岁的时候，本该和一个叫朱莉的女同学去约会，但她却和班上另一个叫迈克尔的男生约好了，因为她没搞清楚自己到底该跟哪个迈克尔约会。他真是一直都……对。安吉拉，这里有个有趣的发现，在这个单人采访中，他说他第二天在学校里听大家议论了整整一天。好吧，你提到他的生日是3月15日。
I have a Dunderpedia catch for you. Okay. They figured out that Michael's 16th birthday would have been March 15th, 1980. That was a Saturday. So the next day would have been Sunday and Michael wouldn't have been at school to hear all about it.
我为你准备了一个邓德百科的发现。好的。他们推算出迈克尔的16岁生日应该是1980年3月15日。那天是星期六。所以第二天就是星期日，迈克尔根本不在学校，不可能听到大家议论这事。
What the heck? What? That's a crazy catch. Get it together. Get it together, writers room. I feel like a kinship with whoever figured out this fact because of the 45 minutes I spent trying to find the Ames and Carbon Dail.
搞什么鬼？什么？这是一个惊人的发现。振作点。编剧组，振作点。我觉得我和发现这个事实的那个人心有灵犀，因为我花了45分钟试图找到埃姆斯和卡本代尔。
Oh yeah, you did. You looked for them for a long, long time. I did. Well, lady, you're a Pisces, you're intense, and you're passionate when the subject moves me. That's right. That's right. And carbon Dale.
哦对，你确实找了。你找了它们好久好久。我确实找了。好吧，姑娘，你是双鱼座，你很情绪化，当这个话题触动我时，你很热情。没错。没错。还有卡本代尔。
Now we're at the right aid with Jim and Pam. Yeah. Extra flirty. You haven't really had an episode in a bit where you two got to be just like flirty, flirty. And so I feel like probably for fans, they were so excited to be like, oh, they're back at it again. They're in in Cahoots. Yes, they bought 69 cup of noodles for Kevin, some M&Ms and his favorite movie, American Pie 2.
现在我们和吉姆和帕姆一起来到了莱德药妆店。是的。超级调情。你们俩已经有一段时间没有这种纯粹调情的戏份了。所以我感觉对于粉丝们来说，他们会超级兴奋地觉得，哦，他们又来了。他们俩又开始串通一气了。是的，他们为凯文买了几大杯69杯的方便面、一些M&M巧克力豆以及他最喜欢的电影《美国派2》。
Oh, man. And then Pam even teases Jim for buying some fabric softener. Oh, she's like, you use fabric softener. And I feel like her internal monologue is like, oh, it's so cute. He does his laundry and he makes sure his clothes are soft. He's going to be a great husband.
天哪。然后帕姆甚至取笑吉姆买了一些衣物柔顺剂。哦，她说，你还用衣物柔顺剂啊。我觉得她心里的独白一定是，哦，太可爱了。他自己洗衣服，还确保衣服洗得软软的。他以后一定会是个好丈夫。
I love him. Oh, well, you know Roy isn't using any fabric softener. Roy's not doing laundry. Exactly. Well, now, next up, Angela is my favorite scene from this whole episode. No cookie. No cookie. Oh, you know, we talk about things that people will say to us when they meet us. I get saved
我太爱他了。哦，好吧，你知道罗伊是绝不用什么衣物柔顺剂的。罗伊才不洗衣服呢。确实。好了，接下来，安吉拉，是整集里我最喜欢的场景。没有曲奇。没有曲奇。哦，你知道的，我们经常谈论粉丝们见到我们时会对我们说的话。我听到的是
bandit and I get no cookie. Well, Dwight and Ryan are in the kitchen and Angela enters and tries to take the cake. The birthday cake from Dwight, but Dwight won't let go of it. But she's the head of the party planning committee. It's her job to bring out the cake. Yes, and they get in a little tiff about it, and then Dwight says, hey, is that meeting to discuss finances still on for later. And Angela's like, fine, fine, but don't expect any cookie. And Dwight says, but what if I'm hungry?
“班迪”和我听到的是“没有曲奇”。好吧，德怀特和莱恩在厨房里，安吉拉走进来想把蛋糕拿走。从德怀特手里拿走生日蛋糕，但德怀特就是不放手。但她是派对策划委员会的负责人。把蛋糕拿出来是她的工作。是的，他们为这事拌了几句嘴，然后德怀特说，嘿，那个讨论财务状况的会议待会儿还开吗。安吉拉就说，行，行，但别指望有什么曲奇。德怀特说，但如果我饿了怎么办？
No, cookie. And then she leaves. And then Ryan's expression, Ryan LBJ, your look is so fantastic. I'm like, what the f did I just witness? What did happen? But then he has that silent talking head. All of that, whatever that minute and a half of television is from the time that scene starts
没曲奇。然后她就走了。接着是莱恩的表情，莱恩·LBJ，你的表情太绝了。我当时就想，我刚才到底目睹了什么鬼？到底发生什么了？但随后他有了一个无声的单人采访。从那个场景开始的
until the end of his talking head is just my favorite from this episode. I loved it. It's so good. BJ's so good. It, it like makes it. It makes it, you know. So now it's happy birthday to Michael.
那漫长的一分半钟的电视画面，直到他的单人采访结束，简直是我这一集中最喜欢的片段。我太喜欢了。太棒了。BJ太棒了。它，它简直点睛了。它太绝了，你知道的。现在是祝迈克尔生日快乐。
The cake is out. The candles are lit. Michael is going to blow out his candles. And at the same time, Kevin gets his phone call. Is it, is it the phone call? No, it's Stacey. Stacey. He says it's Stacey.
蛋糕端出来了。蜡烛点燃了。迈克尔要吹蜡烛了。与此同时，凯文接到了电话。是，是那个电话吗？不，是斯黛西。斯黛西。他说那是斯黛西。
Michael is pissed because his candles aren't trick candles. And this is when everyone's kind of hugging Kevin and Michael's like, you guys stop. What is going on? Angela says very pointedly. No one cares about your birthday, Michael. Yeah. Kevin's waiting to hear if you have skin cancer, Michael.
迈克尔气坏了，因为他的蜡烛不是那种恶作剧蜡烛。这时候大家都在围过去拥抱凯文，而迈克尔却说，你们快停下。这到底是怎么回事？安吉拉非常尖锐地说。没人关心你的生日，迈克尔。对啊。凯文正等着听你有没有皮肤癌呢，迈克尔。
This is like, this is more important. She just like flattens it. She, I mean, she just destroys whatever good mood he was hoping to have. Well, lady, fan comments from Delaney and Kathy O'Dell, they both said, I feel like everyone was really hard on Michael. He didn't know about Kevin. And it was his birthday.
这简直是……这更重要。她简直是当头一棒。她，我是说，她彻底毁掉了他本来期待的好心情。好吧，姑娘，来自德兰妮和凯茜·奥德尔的粉丝评论说，她们俩都觉得，我觉得大家对迈克尔太严厉了。他根本不知道凯文的事。而且那天还是他的生日。
Is his reaction like really that out of line? Well, here's the thing. He's being a little bit of a baby, but I think if any of us really cared about him, the way we should, as his co-workers, someone should have pulled him aside early in the morning and said, hey, listen, Kevin had this biopsy. Here's what's going on. We just want you to know. We don't know if you know. Yeah, right? Right. So that in the moment, he wouldn't be such a jerk because someone would have let him in on it. Now, listen, he still would have been bummed. He still would have spent a ton of energy trying to make everyone somehow find a way to
他的反应真的有那么过分吗？好吧，事情是这样的。他确实有点像个老小孩，但我觉得如果我们当中有任何人真的像同事那样关心他，就应该在清早把他拉到一边说，嘿，听着，凯文做了活检。现在情况是这样的。我们只是想让你知道。我们不知道你知不知道。对吧？对吧？这样在当时那种情况下，他就不会表现得像个混蛋了，因为有人会把实情告诉他。现在，听着，他可能还是会觉得沮丧。他肯定还是会花一大堆精力试图让所有人不知怎么地找到一种方法
be okay celebrating his birthday. Yeah. Which he's going to do later. Okay. Remember earlier, when I told you that behind Jim's talking head, there was a winter scene? Oh, is this the payoff? Give it to me. I want you to notice that in the background
来庆祝他的生日。对啊。他待会儿确实这么做了。好了。大家还记得吗，之前我告诉过大家，在吉姆的单人采访背景里，有一个冬天的场景？哦，这是前面的伏笔吗？快告诉我。我想让你们注意到，在这个生日蜡烛场景的
of this birthday candle scene, my cardigan is draped on the back of my chair. It's a really nice detail because if you notice at the store, I'm not wearing it. I also want you to know that on the coat rack, in a little bit, you're gonna see Pam's giant puffy coat that you're gonna see her wearing later at the ice rink is hanging up,
背景中，我的开衫就搭在椅背上。这是一个非常好的细节，如果你注意到的话，在商店里我并没有穿它。我还想让你们知道，在衣帽架上，一会儿你们会看到帕姆那件巨大的羽绒服，也就是后来你们会看到她在溜冰场穿的那件，挂在那里，
and Jim's big heavy winter coat are on the coat rack. I see what's happening here. Why didn't they take their coats if it's snowing out? If it's so freaking cold that they wore their heavy coats to work that day, why is Pam leaving her cardigan behind and going shopping and just a button-down shirt? What's up? Is it cold out or not cold out? It's cold out. Which one?
还有吉姆厚重的大冬衣也挂在衣帽架上。我明白这里是怎么回事了。外面如果下着雪，他们为什么不带上大衣呢？如果外面冷得要命，他们那天上班才穿了厚大衣，为什么帕姆会把开衫落在办公室，只穿着一件衬衫去购物？这是怎么回事？外面到底是冷还是不冷？外面很冷。到底哪个才是真的？
Someone's slipping on the job there. I don't know. I don't know. It's cold out. Which one? Someone's slipping on the job there. I don't know. I don't know. I'm just saying. Okay. Well, I have a big thing to point out, everyone. What? Okay.
有人工作时马虎了吧。我不知道。我不知道。外面很冷。到底哪个才是真的？有人工作时马虎了吧。我不知道。我不知道。我只是随口说说。好吧。好了，大家，我有一个重要的事情要指出来。什么？好吧。
At 14 minutes, 44 seconds, Jim dares Pam to make an announcement over the store intercom. Because these two are like teenagers. They play jinx by me a coke. Now they're daring each other to do stupid things in public. Jim and Pam, what's going on? But guess what happens? What does Pam do? I know.
在14分44秒时，吉姆打赌帕姆敢不敢通过商店的广播系统发表广播讲话。因为这两个人就像青少年一样。他们玩“双胞游戏”，输了的要请喝可乐。现在他们竟然敢互相怂恿在公共场合做这种蠢事。吉姆和帕姆，你们到底在搞什么鬼？但你们猜怎么着？帕姆做了什么？我知道。
What does she do, Jenna? She, I know, Angela. She says, Luke, this is your father. Star Wars! She makes a Star Wars reference. Janet, did you know what you were doing when you did it? I did because I knew from just, you know,
她做了什么，珍娜？我知道，安吉拉。她说，卢克，我是你父亲。星球大战！她引用了《星球大战》的梗。珍娜，你当时做这件事的时候知道自己在做什么吗？我知道，因为我凭着，你知道的，
pop culture knowledge that there was a movie from the Star Wars movies. Is it Empire Strikes Back? That? Yes, were they're fighting each other? Yes, and it is revealed that Darth Vader is Luke Skywalker's father. He says, I am your father and Luke's like, no, that's not true. I knew the reference, but I did get a fan question from K Slackish 1 who wanted to know if that bit
流行文化的知识，知道《星球大战》系列里有这样一部电影。是《帝国反击战》吗？对，就是他们互相打斗的那部？是的，在片中揭晓了达斯·维德其实是卢克·天行者的父亲。他说，我是你的父亲，而卢克说，不，这不是真的。我懂这个梗，不过我确实收到了一个来自K·斯拉基什1的粉丝提问，他想知道我做那个广播通知的片段
where I make the announcement was improvised, so the Luke line was scripted. However, I didn't improvise a little bit. So when I say I'm sorry into the mic, that was my fun idea and it was a little nod to the movie when Harry Metts Sally. So do you remember the scene in when Harry Metts Sally when Harry and Sally, they're singing karaoke in the store, they're singing Surrey with a friend on top, and Harry's ex-wife starts to walk up and he stops singing and Meg Ryan is like, oh my gosh, it's my voice.
是不是即兴发挥的，其实卢克的那句台词是剧本写好的。不过，我确实即兴发挥了一小部分。所以当我对着麦克风说“对不起”时，那是我的一个好玩的主意，这是向电影《当哈利遇到莎莉》致敬的一个小彩蛋。大家还记得《当哈利遇到莎莉》里的那个场景吗？哈利和莎莉在商店里唱卡拉OK，他们唱着《Surrey with the fringe on top》，这时哈利的阔太太开始走过来，他就不唱了，梅格·瑞恩就说，哦天哪，那是我的声音。
I have the worst voice. And she's saying it all in the microphone. And Harry is like, no, I think I see Helen. And then really loudly into the microphone, Meg Ryan goes, Helen, and it like goes out over the store. I always thought that was such a funny bit. So I thought I'm gonna say, I'm sorry into the mic really loudly. And I don't know, it, I mean, probably no one would ever think about it, but you're inspiration for that moment. I love that.
我的声音太难听了。她这些话全都通过麦克风播出来了。哈利就说，不，我想我看见海伦了。然后梅格·瑞恩非常大声地对着麦克风喊，海伦，声音直接传遍了整个商店。我一直觉得这个桥段太搞笑了。所以我想我也要在麦克风里很大声地说一句“对不起”。我不知道，也许，可能永远不会有人注意到这个细节，但那就是我那个灵感的来源。我太喜欢了。
I think that's so sweet. I also know how much you love when Harry met Sally. It's one of your favorite movies. Lady, when I was in college, I had a three and a half hour drive between St. Louis, which is where my parents still lived, and Kirk's Film Missouri, which is a little rural town in Missouri where I went to college at Truman State University. And what I did to pass the time was I recorded when Harry met Sally onto an audio tape and then I played the movie back for myself in my car on my drive. I have that
我觉得这太甜了。我也知道你有多喜欢《当哈利遇到莎莉》。那是你最喜欢的电影之一。姑娘，我上大学的时候，在我父母当时居住的圣路易斯和密苏里州柯克斯维尔之间，有一段三个半小时的车程，柯克斯维尔是密苏里州的一个小乡村镇，我在那里的杜鲁门州立大学上学。我当时用来打发时间的方法是，把《当哈利遇到莎莉》录在一盘磁带上，然后在我开车的时候在车里放给自己听。我把那整部
entire movie memorized from beginning to end. I love it. That is the sweetest thing. Yeah. I recorded on my tape recorder David Letterman's opening monologues and I would play them back and listen to his opening monologues. Oh my gosh! Well you said you wanted to work for a late-night talk show. I wanted to work in comedy. You love comedy late night. Yeah. Yeah. Ah lady Look, we were meant to be BFFs. We're both driving in our cars. We weren't to things we recorded off of our TVs because we're 100 on our tape decks. Lady, I just got a text from Lee. He sent me a photo of- Is this about your breath? Yeah. Can I go down and check it out? Can we take a break? He made sandwiches for the kids. I want to see if they like it.
电影从头到尾的台词都背下来了。我太爱了。这简直太贴心了。对啊。我在录音机里录下大卫·莱特曼的开场独白，然后我会放出来听他的开场独白。天哪！好吧，你以前说过你想为深夜脱口秀节目工作。我想从事喜剧行业。你很喜欢深夜喜剧。对啊。对啊。啊，姑娘，看，我们注定是要好的闺蜜。我们都在车里开车，我们都会把电视里的节目录下来，因为我们百分之百是磁带党。姑娘，我刚收到李发来的短信。他给我发了一张照片——是因为你的口气吗？对。我可以下去看看吗？我们能休息一下吗？他给孩子们做了三明治。我想看看他们喜不喜欢。
Oh my god, he did it! Way to go Lee! But did they eat it? That's the question we'll find out. Alright, we'll be right back. We're back! Bread report for everyone who's curious. It's freaking delicious, I just ate a slice. Is it? It's good, I don't know if the kids are going to eat it. What does their deal? You know what, Angela?
天哪，他真的做了！干得好，李！但他们吃了吗？这就是我们要揭晓的问题。好了，我们马上回来。我们回来了！给所有好奇的人汇报一下面包的情况。太好吃了，我刚刚吃了一片。是吗？挺好的，我不知道孩子们会不会吃。他们到底怎么回事？你知道吗，安吉拉？
They love all of my other breads. They love my sourdough bread, they love when I make rolls, they love when I make popovers. For whatever reason, I cannot get them to like my sandwich bread. They just want store-bought sandwich bread. I've tried three different recipes. Today will have been my third sandwich bread recipe. I don't know. Or they will like it the day it comes out of the oven, but the next day it's a no-go for them. They only want it warm out of the oven. I don't know. Shall we get back into this episode, Melody? I think we should. Where are we?
他们喜欢我做的所有其他面包。他们喜欢我的酸面包，喜欢我做的卷饼，喜欢我做的泡芙。出于某种原因，我就是没办法让他们喜欢我的三明治面包。他们只想吃买来的那种三明治面包。我已经试过三个不同的食谱了。今天已经是我做的第三种三明治面包食谱了。我不知道。要么就是他们会在刚出炉的那天吃，但第二天就坚决不吃了。他们只想吃刚出炉热乎的。我不知道。梅洛迪，我们要不要继续聊这一集？我觉得我们应该继续。我们讲到哪儿了？
I believe that we are back in human resources. 15 minutes, 15 seconds. Kevin is talking to Toby about his skin cancer. Yeah, and this is a nice call back to season one's health care episode because Toby's like, can you get on your fiance's health care plan because honestly, arts is horrible. That's right. So to me, to me, it was a nice call back to the health care episode. Well, Michael comes over with a bunch of facts that are about why Kevin shouldn't be worried.
我想我们回到了人力资源部。15分15秒。凯文在和托比谈论他的皮肤癌。是的，这很好地呼应了第一季的医疗保险那一集，因为托比说，你能加入你未婚妻的医疗保险计划吗，因为老实说，我们的保险太烂了。没错。所以对我来说，这很好地呼应了医疗保险那一集。好吧，迈克尔走过来，说了一堆事实，试图证明凯文其实不用担心。
He's got some statistics. The subtext is why we can still celebrate Michael's birthday without any problem, but he's presenting it as why Kevin shouldn't be worried. Yeah. And then Toby's like, you know, kind of gives him some Toby sass. And Michael's like, why are you here? And Toby's like, I work here. Well, now Michael is going to announce that they're going somewhere and it's to make Kevin feel better. There's an outing for the whole office. But of course, if you remember in an earlier scene,
他列举了一些统计数据。潜台词其实是，为什么我们仍然可以毫无问题地庆祝迈克尔的生日，但他却把这包装成“为什么凯文不应该担心”。是的。然后托比就，你知道的，用托比式的傲慢回怼了他一下。迈克尔就说，你为什么在这儿？托比说，我在这里工作。好吧，现在迈克尔要宣布他们要出去一趟，说是为了让凯文感觉好点。全办公室的人都要去郊游。但当然，如果你还记得前面那个场景，
Michael asked Dwight if he's made all the plans for later. So this has been a matter. Oh, there's a big banner when we walk in. So that's how we birthday, Michael. Like this was planned for sure. Not by the party planning committee, by the way, Angela would not allocate funds to this. No. But Dwight had this, he had planned it. We had a fan question from Noelle, Angela, because we're about to go to the ice skating rink now. And that's the big surprise that he's
迈克尔问德怀特是否已经把接下来的计划都做好了。所以这其实是一早就安排好的。哦，我们走进去的时候有一条巨大的横幅。所以大家是怎么庆祝迈克尔生日的呢。这绝对是计划好的。顺便说一句，可不是派对策划委员会策划的，安吉拉才不会为此拨付资金呢。没错。但德怀特早就计划好了。安吉拉，我们收到了诺埃尔的粉丝提问，因为我们现在要去溜冰场了。这就是他给我们准备的巨大惊喜，
taking us all ice skating. And Noelle wanted to know, did you have a safety meeting about ice skating? Remember, safety meeting lit candle. I'm sure we did. I'm sure there was a safety meeting about we have heavy things being held on the ice. I'm sure there was all kinds of safety meetings. Well, I know we had a medic there, and the reason that I know this is because,
他带着我们全办公室的人去溜冰。诺埃尔想知道，你们去溜冰前开过安全会议吗？大家还记得安全会议上点燃的蜡烛吗？我敢说我们肯定开过。我敢肯定肯定开过关于“我们要拿着重物在冰面上滑行”的安全会议。我敢肯定有各种各样的安全会议。好吧，我知道我们在现场有个医疗急救人员，我之所以知道这一点是因为，
I don't know if you remember Angela, but Mindy fell while we were shooting. I don't remember that. And she hurt her knee. So you know there's that little bit of the ice skating rink where Kelly is helping Ryan. Yeah. Well, she fell and she heard her knee
我不知道你还记不记得，安吉拉，明迪在拍摄时摔倒了。我不记得了。她伤了膝盖。所以你们知道溜冰场上有个小片段，凯莉在帮莱恩。对。好吧，她摔倒了，弄伤了膝盖，
and the medic had to give her some ice, but she was able to finish filming. Her knee was okay. I thought it was interesting when you saw the different couplings of people ice skating. In the beginning, you see Kelly and Ryan. You see Pam and Jim. I sort of just kind of go around solo.
医疗人员不得不给她一些冰块冷敷，但她还是坚持完成了拍摄。她的膝盖没事。我觉得当看到大家在冰场上各种不同的搭档组合时，挺有意思的。一开始，你看到凯莉和莱恩。你看到帕姆和吉姆。我呢，基本上就是一个人单独到处转转。
Yeah. So this is right. We just kind of, we don't want anyone to know. We're seeing each other. So we skate alone. And then later, you see Ryan and Phyllis holding hands and ice skating. Yes, at 19 minutes. We had a fan catch by KP who said I love when you see Ryan and Phyllis at the skating rink holding hands so Ryan won't fall. It's such a random glimpse into their friendship.
是的。所以这很对。我们只是，我们不想让任何人知道。我们在悄悄交往。所以我们独自滑冰。然后后来，你看到莱恩和菲利斯手拉手在冰上滑冰。是的，在19分钟的时候。我们收到了KP的粉丝留言，他说我最喜欢看到莱恩和菲利斯在溜冰场手拉手，这样莱恩就不会摔倒了。这真是对他们友谊的一个非常随意的惊鸿一瞥。
I think Angela, they did that because Mindy was icing her knee. And what's really cute if you watch it is Phyllis is so tickled. She's so tickled. It's just really cute. It's very, very sweet. And I actually, I went back after I read that comment and I watched it and it's really very sweet to see the two of them skating together.
我想，安吉拉，他们之所以这么做，是因为明迪当时在给膝盖冰敷。如果你仔细看的话，非常可爱的一点是菲利斯觉得太逗了。她觉得太好玩了。真的非常可爱。非常非常甜蜜。其实，看完那条评论后，我又回去看了一遍，看到他们俩一起溜冰，真的觉得非常甜蜜。
So that was an accident. I had another fan question from Live Long, California. Did you and John know how to ice skate? Or did you have to learn for this episode? So here's something interesting in this episode. Jim is kind of helping Pam on the ice. But right before we film this episode, I had actually been in some intense ice skating training
所以那是个意外。我还有来自加州“长寿”的另一个粉丝提问：你和约翰本来就会溜冰吗？还是为了这一集专门去学的？所以这一集里有个有趣的地方。吉姆在冰上帮帕姆。但在我们拍摄这一集之前，我其实一直在接受密集的溜冰训练，
because I was filming a movie with Will Ferrell called Blades of Glory. And yeah, every Saturday morning for a few months, I had to go early in the morning and spend about three hours learning to ice skate and the crazy thing is my character didn't even ice skate in the movie. I am completely pretending to not know how to ice skate in this scene on the office because I had actually just... I mean, kind of learned how to ice skate quite well thanks on the office because I had actually just, I mean, kind of learned how to ice skate quite well thanks to this movie training. You're describing my fantasy, but all I ever wanted was to be cast
因为我当时在和威尔·法瑞尔拍一部名叫《荣誉之刃》的电影。是的，连续几个月，每个星期六早上，我都得一大早去花大约三个小时学习溜冰，最疯狂的是，我的角色在电影里根本不用溜冰。我在《办公室》这个场景里完全是在假装自己不会溜冰，因为我其实刚刚……我是说，多亏了电影的训练，我已经把溜冰学的相当不错了。这简直是在描述我的白日梦，我一直以来最渴望的就是能参演
in something where they're like, listen, Angela, you're gonna have to learn kung fu. You're gonna go every Saturday, you're gonna become a kung fu master, or you're gonna have to learn how to throw an axe. You're going to get really good at throwing axes. Like, I wanted to learn something like that, but it's never happened.
这样一部作品，剧组会说，听着，安吉拉，你得去学功夫。你每个星期六都要去，你要成为一个功夫大师，或者你得学习怎么扔斧子。你要把扔斧子练得炉火纯青。我就想学点这种技能，但这种事从来没发生过。
Well speaking of skating, Michael is zipping around in his hockey gear. So in the background of Michael's talking head, it's around 17 minutes, 42 seconds. There's a really great shot of that professional ice skater, Bert Lankin, who stands in for Oscar. He's doing a bunch of twirls. It's just sort of fun. You realize nothing with you, though, Ange. I know nothing with me, but do you realize one of the office members who's not on the ice
说到溜冰，迈克尔穿着全套冰球装备在冰上飞驰。所以在迈克尔单人采访的背景里，大约是17分42秒左右。有一个非常棒的镜头，拍的是奥斯卡的替身、专业溜冰运动员伯特·兰金。他在那里转了好几个圈。这其实挺好玩的。不过安吉，你会发现你可不在其中。我知道我不在其中，但你有没有发现，办公室里有个没上冰的人
is Creed? And it's because he's in the arcade playing a shoot him up game with a bunch of kids. Oh, yes, that's right. That's right. Well, there's also that scene where Michael checks Toby into the wall. Yeah. We had a fan question from Cardinals fan. Was Toby harmed in the making of that scene?
是克里德？那是因为他在街机厅里和一群小屁孩玩枪战游戏呢。哦，对，没错。没错。好吧，还有那个迈克尔把托比撞到墙上的场景。是的。我们收到了来自红雀队球迷的粉丝提问：拍那个场景时托比受伤了吗？
No. And if you watch closely, Steve's body never really touches Toby. Like he really, like Steve, I think because he's so good, he kind of slams into the wall and makes a noise with his arms. And then Paul just sort of falls to the ground himself. No, Steve had total control, but it's because he's such a good skater. And so he could definitely sort of show off a little bit and do all that stuff. Oh, this was for sure one of Steve's favorite film days, I think.
没有。如果你仔细看的话，史蒂夫的身体其实根本没碰到托比。就像他真的……史蒂夫，我觉得因为他技术太好了，他只是猛地冲向墙壁，然后用手臂制造出了撞击的声音。接着保罗自己顺势倒在了地上。不，史蒂夫完全掌控了，但那是因为他是个滑冰高手。所以他绝对可以稍微炫耀一下，做所有那些动作。哦，这绝对是史蒂夫最喜欢的拍摄日之一，我觉得。
I need to be. He had to be. He had to be. He was having the best time. Yeah. And also, he had the best time because Nancy Carrell, his wife in real life, shows up in this episode again as Carol Stills, a real estate agent. She's on the ice rink. But Michael's so innocent. He's like,
必须是的。肯定是。他肯定乐在其中。是的。而且，他之所以觉得太棒了，是因为他在现实生活中的妻子南茜·卡瑞尔在这一集中再次出演，饰演房地产经纪人卡尔·斯蒂尔斯。她也在溜冰场上。但迈克尔太单纯了。他说，
oh, was this for sale? And she's like, no, Michael, like, I can go, I can go places that aren't for sale, you know, like, my kids are here to ice skate. And then he's so sweet with the kids. He's so sweet. And we sort of found that like Michael probably could have tried to play professional hockey, but he didn't think it was a great job to have if you want a family. And that's all he wants. So it's just this theme again that Michael just wants a family. That's what he wants. Well, you know, when he offers to pull the kids around the ice rink with his hockey stick, he's skating he wants. Well, you know when he offers to pull the kids around the ice rank with his hockey stick, he's skating backwards and he's pulling the kids, Lee does that all the time with our kids.
哦，这个地方是要出售的吗？她就说，不，迈克尔，我是说，我可以去那些并不打算出售的地方，你知道的，比如我的孩子们来这里溜冰。然后他对孩子们超级温柔。他太温柔了。我们隐约觉得迈克尔本来也许可以尝试去打职业冰球的，但他觉得如果你想要组建家庭的话，这不是一份理想的工作。而这正是他唯一想要的东西。所以这又回归了那个主题：迈克尔只是想要一个家庭。这就是他想要的。好吧，你知道的，当他提出用冰球棍拉着孩子们在溜冰场转圈时，他倒着滑冰，
Aw. So when I saw that, I was like, oh, I think that's like a hockey guy thing to do. You pull your kids around as they hold onto the hockey stick. You just turned into like a 16 year old girl, googly eyes. You just thought about your husband. I know.
拉着孩子们，李经常对我们的孩子们这样做。哦。所以当我看到那一幕时，我就想，哦，我觉得这大概是冰球运动员的拿手好戏吧。拉着孩子们，让他们抓着冰球棍。你刚才突然变得像个16岁的小姑娘一样，眼里闪着崇拜的小星星。你刚才满脑子都是你老公。我知道。
I wish you could have seen Jenna just now. She just literally did this weird thing with her shoulder and she kind of tossed her hair and she was like, I think it's a hockey guy thing. Like it was, what just happened to you? Clearly, when you saw your husband do that, you're like, yails, Yales, baby. I get real smitten with him sometimes especially when he does you know when he's on the ice.
我真希望你们刚才看到珍娜的样子。她刚才字面意义上地用肩膀做了一个奇怪的动作，然后把头发一甩，说了一句“我觉得这是个冰球男的常规操作”。那句话说得，你刚才到底怎么了？很显然，当你看到你老公那样做时，你心里就在想，太帅了，宝贝。我有时真的对她老公神魂颠倒，尤其是当他在冰上的时候。
Fathering. Yeah. Um, on the ice being a great dad. Okay. Now Kevin gets the phone call. Everyone skates around him. Jenna, I remember filming this because we had to time it out. And there were a bunch of us on the ice that skate up to where he is.
展现父亲风范的时候。对。呃，在冰上当个好爸爸。好了。现在凯文接到了电话。大家都在他周围滑冰。珍娜，我还记得拍摄这场戏的情景，因为我们必须掌握好时间。我们有一大群人都在冰上，朝着他所在的地方滑过去。
Do you remember this? Yes, and we have to all be able to stop. I didn't know how to stop. Yeah. That was my one problem. I didn't know how to stop. So I remember trying to like push really hard to slow myself down. So I didn't run into people,
你还记得吗？记得，而且我们都必须能够停下来。我当时根本不会停下来。对。那是我的唯一难题。我不会停下来。所以我记得自己当时拼命想用力刹车来减速，免得撞到别人，
but I was like stressed out. Well guess what? His results are negatives. Which is a good thing. You want your Michael to be negative. The likes to be negative. Doesn't understand that. No, Michael's like, Michael is gutted.
但我当时压力山大。好吧，你们猜怎么着？他的检测结果是阴性的。这是件好事。你当然希望你的迈克尔是阴性的。检查结果喜欢阴性。他不明白这一点。不，迈克尔觉得，迈克尔简直心碎了。
He's like, oh no, this is horrible. We're gonna beat this. And he has that amazing talking head where he's like, oh no, this is horrible. We're gonna beat this. And he has that amazing talking head where he's like, it turns out that in the medical field, negative is a good thing. Now, in the real world, negative means bad, but when it comes to test results, it was, it was one of those that you love, Angela,
他觉得，哦不，这太可怕了。我们要战胜它。然后他有了一段精彩绝伦的单人采访，他说，哦不，这太可怕了。我们要战胜它。然后他有了一段精彩绝伦的单人采访，他说，原来在医学领域，阴性是个好东西。在现实世界中，阴性意味着坏事，但当谈到检测结果时，这正是你最喜欢的桥段，安吉拉，
where he's describing things to us that the rest of us all know. One of my favorite things is when Michael is like, I'm going to break this down for you. This is what it's like information we all know. This is probably coming as a surprise to you too. Yeah, I know. I'm going to tell you how. It turned out.
他向我们解释一些我们大家其实都已经知道的事情。我最喜欢的事情之一就是迈克尔说，我要给你们好好剖析一下。这就是诸如此类的信息，其实我们大家都知道。这可能对你来说也挺意外的吧。对，我懂。我要告诉你们怎么回事。结果证明……
Yeah. Yes. Well, now we're opening gifts, lady. I know. I love this scene. We're opening gifts. I have actually I love this scene we're opening gifts I have actually been in the room where we filmed I'd been there before because I'd been to a kids birthday party And if you have a kids birthday party at this particular rank
对。是的。好吧，现在我们要拆礼物了，姑娘。我知道。我太喜欢这个场景了。我们在拆礼物。我其实去过我们拍摄这个场景的那个房间，我以前就去过那里，因为我曾经去参加过一个小孩的生日派对。如果你在这个特定的溜冰场举办小孩生日派对，
Number one your birthday child gets to ride the Zamboni around the ice one time Oh, yes, and then you get to have all of your birthday cake and presents in this room where we were. So it kind of cracked me up that this is where Michael's birthday would be because he's so childlike. So we're sitting at this table. Kevin gets a card that says, get well soon or something like that. But it's got a lady in a bikini. This clearly made his day. He's going to save that. Maybe he'll put it with some of the things he keeps on his computer. Because he's a little pervy. He's very happy about this card.
第一，你的寿星孩子可以坐一次赞博尼清冰车绕冰面转一圈，哦，对，然后你就可以在这个我们所在的房间里吃生日蛋糕和拆礼物了。所以这让我觉得挺好笑的，迈克尔的生日居然会在这种地方过，因为他太有童心了。所以我们坐在桌子旁。凯文收到了一张卡片，上面写着“祝早日康复”之类的话。但上面印着一个穿比基尼的女人。这绝对让他开心极了。他打算把这张卡片好好珍藏。也许他会把它和那些保存在电脑里的东西放在一起。因为他有点色迷迷的。他对这张卡片非常满意。
He loves it. And then Michael gets a Wilkesbury penguins hockey jersey from Dwight. This is a real team. It actually, well, and it says from Dwight. From Dwight number one, I have been to their rank, me and Craig Robinson, Brian Bob Gardner, Kate Flannery for the first ever office convention we got to go. We got to go on the ice. We all got a jersey. I still have my jersey. That's amazing. Yeah. So they're the AHL team. So they're not the NHL team. They're the AHL team. And that's, yeah, real
他爱不释手。然后迈克尔收到了德怀特送的一件威尔克斯巴里企鹅队的冰球球衣。这是一支真实存在的球队。实际上，而且，上面写着“来自德怀特”。来自德怀特第一名，我去过他们的冰场，我和克雷格·罗宾逊、布赖恩·鲍勃·加德纳、凯特·弗兰内利一起去的，那是我们参加的第一届办公室粉丝大会。我们上了冰面。我们每人都得到了一件球衣。我还留着我的球衣呢。太棒了。对。所以他们是AHL（美国冰球联盟）的球队。所以他们不是NHL（国家冰球联盟）的球队。他们是AHL的球队。而且那是，是的，一支真正的
hockey team. Real hockey team and their mascot is tux the penguin Everyone there was really really nice. That was that was super fun. Well then Pam gives Michael Night swept from everyone big says it's from everyone. Yes. Yeah Yes from everyone in the office we had a fan question from boss lady Is there really a cologne called Night Sweeped? Well, this.
冰球队伍。真正的冰球队伍，他们的吉祥物是企鹅图克斯。那里的每个人都真的非常好。那次真的超级好玩。然后帕姆送给迈克尔“夜扫”香水，说是大家送的，大声说这是大家送的。是的。是的。是的，是办公室里的每个人送的。我们收到了来自“老板娘”的粉丝提问：真的有一种古龙水叫“夜扫”吗？好吧，这个。
There's not, but Jenna, did you know this is a callback? Did you catch this? Yes. So from Hot Girl. And they're cleaning out his car. Yes, in season one, episode six, Hot Girl, Ryan and Michael are cleaning out his car. And Michael says that's my
并没有，但是珍娜，你知道这是一个呼应吗？你注意到了吗？是的。来自“辣妹”那一集。他们在清理他的车。是的，在第一季第六集《辣妹》中，莱恩和迈克尔在清理他的车。迈克尔说那是我的
dracar nor, right? Is that how you say that? Yeah. And Ryan's like no, it's right a night swept and Michael's like, uh-uh, it's a perfect smell alike. I'm not paying for the label. So he's probably very excited. He likes night swept and he already is a buyer of night swept And here he gets a four pack. He got lotion, cologne, some kind of body spray maybe. Yes, that was all packaged and created by Phil Shea. That is a fictional cologne line. However, I just want to let you know that I did Google Night Sweat
“Drakkar Noir”，对吧？是这么发音的吗？对。莱恩就说，不，那是莱德的“夜扫”，迈克尔就说，呃-呃，这俩味道一模一样。我才不会为牌子多花冤枉钱呢。所以他可能超级兴奋。他喜欢“夜扫”，而且他本来就是“夜扫”的买家，在这里他直接收到了四件套。他得到了乳液、古龙水，可能还有某种身体喷雾。是的，所有这些都是由菲尔·谢伊打包制作的。那是一个虚构的古龙水系列。不过，我只是想让你们知道，我确实谷歌搜索了一下“夜汗”，
and there is a Christian-based mystery novel by writer Marvin Reame called Night Sweat and it's available on Amazon. Okay. There you have it. For super fans out there who might wanna read a book called Night Sweat. It doesn't smell like anything from what I would assume
确实有一本由作家马文·里姆撰写的基督教惊悚小说叫《夜汗》，在亚马逊上买得到。好吧。这就是了。献给可能想读一本叫《夜汗》的书的超级粉丝们。据我所知，它闻起来可没有什么香味，
since it's a book and it's not a cologne. There you go. There you go. Where are we? It's the end of the episode. That's it. And it ends this episode with a talking head. She says it was a good day. Angela, because of what you said earlier, which is that, you know,
毕竟它是一本书，而不是古龙水。就是这样。就是这样。我们到哪儿了？这一集快结束了。就是这样。这一集以一段单人采访结束。她说这真是美好的一天。安吉拉，正如你刚才所说的那样，
finally we get a little flirty flirt for her and Jim. They got to go shopping. She got to learn he uses fabrics off her. I mean, this was a good day for Pam. She got to pretend what it would be like maybe to be Jim's girlfriend for a day. And run an errand. Run errands together and she loved it.
总算，她和吉姆之间有了一点小小的调情。他们去购物了。她发现他会使用衣物柔顺剂。我是说，对帕姆来说，这是美好的一天。她得以假装了一天作为吉姆的女朋友会是什么感觉。一起去跑腿。一起办杂货，她太喜欢了。
She loved it. So it was a good day. And Michael had a great birthday. As it turns out, he got to ice skate. He got a present he liked. Kevin was going to be okay. So it all ended well. It did. But before we say goodbye to Michael's birthday, there is a deleted scene that I have to read. I'm not going to tell you anything about it. It's a Dwight talking head. I'm going to read it and then I'm going to just watch your reaction. Okay? All right. Okay. This is okay. Deleted scene of a Dwight talking head from Michael's birthday. Michael's birthday is hard for me because he gets very excited. But he's also under a lot of pressure, which builds up until he's ready
她太喜欢了。所以这是美好的一天。迈克尔也过了一个棒极了的生日。事实证明，他去溜冰了。他收到了一件自己喜欢的礼物。凯文也没事了。所以一切都有了一个好结局。确实如此。但就在我们向迈克尔的生日告别之前，有一个删减片段我必须读一下。我不会剧透任何内容。这是一个德怀特单人采访。我要读一下，然后我就静静地看你的反应。好吧？好吧。好吧。这是个删减片段，关于来自迈克尔生日的德怀特单人采访。迈克尔的生日对我来说很难熬，因为他会变得非常兴奋。但他也承受着巨大的压力，这种压力不断累积，直到他准备好
to explode. As his right hand man, it's my job to release that pressure so that he can enjoy himself, if only for a moment. Wow. That is brilliant. That is brilliant. That is a delightful, delightful talking head, written by Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stupnitzky. Right. That's right in their willhouse, but you know it probably was hard for rain to get through that. For sure. Guys, that's it. That's Michael's birthday. We celebrated Michael's birthday. Happy birthday, Michael. We hope you had a good time. Thanks for coming along for the ride. Next week, we're going to do some drug testing. Dwight, why is your urine green? We'll find out.
爆发。作为他的得力助手，我的工作就是释放这种压力，让他能够享受片刻的快乐，哪怕只有一会儿。哇。这太绝了。这太绝了。这是一个令人愉悦至极的单人采访，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基撰写。没错。这完全符合他们的风格，但你懂的，雷恩要一本正经地念完这段台词肯定不容易。好了，各位，就是这样。这就是迈克尔的生日。我们庆祝了迈克尔的生日。生日快乐，迈克尔。我们希望你度过了一个美好的时光。感谢大家陪我们度过这段旅程。下周，我们要进行药物检测了。德怀特，你的尿液为什么是绿色的？我们拭目以待。
Oof! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Scher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jirkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哎呀！感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍妮弗·沙尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·吉尔金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。当前还没有针对本集的评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。